so we got this new uh Republican speaker
of the house and the good news is he
says there's insufficient evidence to
impeach Joe Biden and he gave a great
speech where he said look impeachment
requires these things and though we have
evidence of these things we don't have
evidence evidence of those things so
we're not going to be able to impeach
him and I'm seeing a lot of people are
kind of angry about it but I you know I
I got to be honest uh I'm actually happy
about it I am now a I'm I'm Pro Biden uh
ladies and gentlemen I want Joe Biden to
be the Democratic nominee I am happy
that the Republicans have have uh saw
the have have seen it clearly and
understand now that Joe is a great guy
and should stay president and he should
be the Democrat nominee in 20124 I
strongly hope that is the case why
because Trump is leading in five of six
swing States and Democrats actually want
Joe Biden out here's what's funny when
we hear the news that the GOP is saying
insufficient evidence
you try pulling up stories no no news
out is running a headline breaking
Republicans say no impeachment of Biden
they're not doing it they're running
these passive headlines of like
impeachment may be slowing down because
the Democrats and the corporate press
are like uhoh we needed the Republicans
to boot Joe Biden and now that he's in
how we going to win so we'll talk about
that a couple other stories you know
just whatever it's ER Eric Adams got
raided by the FBI you may have heard the
story but his phones have been SE
something to do with donations to Turkey
it's getting crazy out there but it's
Friday night so we're chilling before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.net
why get them while you can indoctrinate
them first the left is going to come and
argue to take away their rights and say
they don't have a right to defend
themselves and they're going to they're
going to just splatter propaganda on
their faces we made this to explain why
you need the right to keep in bare arms
aside from crime it's fun but also more
importantly democide how governments
historically have killed their own
people and how these problems have come
to be if we do not remember our past we
are doomed to repeat it so definitely
check us out at Tim cast.com become a m
we also have membersonly uncensored
shows Monday through Thursday none of
those up today but we do have the
members only Discord where you can hang
out with like-minded individuals and
they have their own shows running and
there will be an after show in the
Discord so check it out smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends as I
mentioned become a member at Tim
cast.com joining us tonight to talk
about this and everything else is Taylor
Hansen good to be here who are you what
do you do name's Taylor Hansen as you
said and I am a field reporter for
tenant media umop guy I thought that was
you the umop guy too apparently yeah I
get that uh we did our first episode of
the culture war on tenet media on
YouTube so definitely subscribe to that
we're we're we're we're super excited
about this basically we're going to have
like this Independent Media super group
thing going on so there's going to be a
lot a lot of really awesome content and
I'll just say right now one of the one
of the the best things for us it's a one
show a week we're going to be doing with
tenant media in the mornings the culture
War but basically it's a it's a it's a
major cross promotional uh benefit for
all of us that you know when when
Taylor's doing his reporting when we're
doing culture War the people who find
our podcast or find his reporting there
there's crossover and so it's going to
be very very beneficial coming into this
uh uh uh presidential election cycle so
super excited to have you man can't wait
Hannah Clair's hanging out hey I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
but it's Carter Bank yes yes trash House
Records um timcast music producer Carter
Banks got stuff coming up is just gone I
am he was talking smack about how he's
going to beat everybody in poker and
then didn't show up I was supposed to
lift with him today ghosted ghosted man
he's probably playing Ballers Gate 3 he
was he was live streaming about uh I
think he was live streaming about uh the
underground city or something like that
well you know he whatever flot is boat
we got Serge pressing the buttons yes
I'm here uh on Friday it's just a new
one for me but I'm excited it's always
good to see you Taylor always pleasure
let's do it to him here's the breaking
headline from The Washington Post
momentum behind impeachment increase
slows under new speaker now hold on
there a minute why aren't they running
the major headline of Speaker of the
House says no impeachment they want Joe
Biden impeached they're like come on
Republicans you have to walk into this
one so we have this video Ed kenin you
know you love him he tweets out this
video Let's play uh play the clip for
you so you can uh hear it yourself as to
why he's saying no impeachment at this
time I mean let this be an open
invitation to President Biden I know the
White House is is recording all this
they're watching what we do here here's
the open invitation
President Biden secretary blinkin any of
the Biden family members and Associates
or anyone who seeks to clear their name
anybody involved in this investigation
at all you can come right here you are
welcome here in Congress to our
committees we on the house Judiciary
Committee house oversight committee
weaponization committee the Ways and
Means Committee any other pick your
committee and we'll bring you in and you
can clear your name Mr Speaker we would
love to return our full Focus to our
regular and important work here but the
facts in our sworn oath to defend the
Constitution require this inquiry and I
I'll close this with this and I'm going
to bring up a couple of my colleagues
who will share their thoughts as well
but remember that Article 1 Section two
of the Constitution itself expressly
states that the sole power of
impeachment belongs here to this house
and then Article 2 Section 4 says listen
to the language carefully it's expressly
written in the Constitution this is not
political talking points we're not
making this up it says in Article 2
Section 4 that the president shall be
removed from office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors my
friends I just listed just a small
sample just the tip of the
iceberg of of the credible allegations
and the mounting evidence that shows
that Joseph
Biden has engaged in bribery schemes
payto playay schemes this is what the
evidence shows and now for the best part
here is the quote from the speaker of
the house there is insufficient evidence
at the moment to initiate formal
impeachment proceedings against Joe
Biden so after hearing what he just said
now you have it from The Washington Post
as well you have the tweet from Mike
cernovich he says congratulations
everyone that's his quote so why why the
change of uh why why why the why they
change of pace here and I think it's
fairly obvious Democrats actually want
him impeached and convicted and the
Republicans like Mike Johnson previously
was saying yes look what he's done we
have evidence we have these checks all
of a sudden he's saying there's
insufficient evidence to to to move
forward yeah they want Biden to stay
yeah it's kind of hilarious that the
Washington Post headline is sort of
scolding Mike Johnson for being for for
not moving forward with the impeachment
we all theoretically wanted for a while
but it just goes to show you the DNC
absolutely hates Biden and maybe it's
just a 4D chess move I mean they know
that Biden is the weakest candidate here
and if they can keep him in and allow
him to essentially ruin the country for
as long as he has and the rest of his
election um you know I think uh I think
they know what they're doing here I kind
of feel the same way it does seem like
they're they've got all this stuff out
in the open it's pretty obvious that he
should be impeachable but he is not
they're not going to impeach him so this
is the Washington Post says it this way
in a closed door meeting with House GOP
moderates this week he indicated that
there is insufficient evidence at the
moment to initiate formal impeachment
proceedings according to people who
attended the meeting we'll just go where
the evidence goes and we're not there
yet and then you have from the Hill 4
days ago Mike Johnson has accused Biden
of bribery now impeachment is in his
hands you
see as he's coming into the speakership
this is what the guy was all about now
that he's there what is this right I'm
not so convinced right Mike cernovich
said congratulations everybody but I'm
not so convinced it's a bad thing I I
stated this in the intro I am I Am pro
Joe Biden let's let's let's keep Joe
Biden in there hey he should be the
Democrat nominee stop is personally
campaigning for Joe Biden right now
absolutely absolutely I I I don't
understand the argument as to why I I
mentioned this before when a lot of
people were saying why aren't they
impeaching him now why do they keep
saying things like this I was like maybe
they're waiting for an October surprise
yeah you want to wait you look we're
we're a year away from the election
that's an eternity in in in an election
I mean judging by metrics on on view
counts on videos right we're going to
get a month out it's going to be nuts
everyone's going to be watching eyes
glued to everything you want to maximize
the story you impeach him right now now
the story disappears in 3 months and
then what nothing I'm assuming the
Republicans I assumed they would
probably try they they would move for an
inquiry and then impeach him some way
down the line now I'm thinking they're
not going to impeach him at all and I'm
all for it let him stay let him stay
seems like they're just using him as a
like a shield scapegoat down the line
well and if Biden got impeached and
Kamala became president it actually
would potentially set her up for a run
for the White House permanently and I
don't think anyone wants that including
the DNC she's historically unpop
and I think generally it looks like the
DNC ultimately wants to run Nome and so
impeaching Joe Biden gets them a half
step closer but it's not perfect the RNC
knows that ultimately Joe Biden is their
best bet because he is splitting his own
voters in every direction you can see
and so it it even though the RNC doesn't
know who they want to run it's probably
going to be Trump they know that Biden
is the best opposition because he'll
avoid debates and the American public
doesn't trust or like him states are a
perfect example of his support right now
and they're not looking good but I just
got to say like this statement of
insufficient evidence is BS everyone
knows it especially and and if you're a
Democrat you're probably you're probably
oping under the assumption that the
Republicans are lying about their view
of the evidence too because they just
put out what is it two different checks
was it $40,000 and
$200,000 Mike Johnson himself claimed
has evidence of bribery mhm for
impeachment and now he's walking it back
this is funny because it's like it
reminds me of the beginning of Co when
Republic when it was people on the right
being like wear masks quick and fouchi
was like you don't need to be wearing
masks and then like within a month Fu
was like it's best to wear two masks and
then every all the conservatives are
like no you can't make me wear a mask
I'm like is this is a weird game of cat
and mouse or something is the question
then Our House Republicans actually
doing a disservice to the American
people if they know that he's
impeachable even if it's strategically
for the election it's better to leave
Biden in are they doing are they failing
in their own responsib I ities by not
impeaching him right I'd say that's I
mean that's yes they're failing in their
responsibilities but if you want to win
an election you got to do things like
this and clearly we have lost election
after election after election I mean you
saw VC Teran toon McDaniel on the stage
oh it was amazing it was beautiful it
was the best debate performance uh
debate performance I've ever seen and
you know some people said yeah but what
about Trump no no Trump had his moments
but VI across the board every step of
the way I would say Trump's key moments
like only Rosie O'Donnell and you'd be
in jail individually as moments are the
best moments of debates but the
sustained performance of V had just
ripping the machine to shreds I think
was the best overall but I I was told
that Nikki Haley won okay that is true
she won in our hearts and Minds just not
in actual reality she didn't win
anywhere for me I'm just kidding no I
think part of the the thing about Trump
is that he just su he is a sustained I
can't talk tonight sustained performance
through throughout his whole campaign
right there is a personality people who
go to his rallies really feel affected
by them he's able to draw support that
way and I think you see the Charisma
that vake has and that is potentially
great the problem here is that the rnc's
preferred candidates like Nikki Haley
and Ronda santis can't handle it they
they aren't performing on this level and
the RNC is not willing to recruit and
work with someone who has that level of
Charisma I want to give a shout out to
our friend Ed kenin over here liberal
personality on Twitter who said it's all
theater it's all an attempt to create
these bogus headlines of corruption
bribery and Biden crime family Nars
that's right this is I am outraged Joe
Biden is a good man he is an American
hero and we should keep him in office to
run again hey I'm I'm Pro Biden all the
way now let's go now that we're seeing
the swing state polls we're like no
Biden stay cuz they're going to bring in
someone else look it can only go up with
Newsome I don't know if new Newsome can
beat Trump but like Biden leaving it
only goes up however I do want to say it
would be very satisfying to see Biden
both impeached and convicted as the
first president to be convicted that' be
you know I don't know but rather have
trumpy President they're Pros to all
sorts of situations I mean obviously I
think RFK is like no no leave Biden
where he is because it it is uh perfect
for All The Independents running this
year you know Jill Stein just announced
she's going to run with the green party
like oh did she really she's back she's
back just like and I mean that should be
a tell of itself that the fact that all
of The Independents who are coming out
ultimately
no matter what the mainstream media
tells you Hemorrhage voters away from
Biden who can't keep them anyways
because they think he's too old and they
not confident his performance the best
thing he can do for Republicans is stay
where he where he is because he's a
roadblock for the
DNC yeah agree theoretically if he did
all these things wrong he should be
impeached and so it is it is interesting
what is the right path forward winning
yeah prob and so it's like how about we
just impeach him after he loses we let
him run Trump wins and then we impeach
him because you can you can do
post-presidential impeachments that's
what they did to Trump and you can do it
and then we'll criminally charge him and
convict him and he can share a jail cell
with his son they'll play Scrabble
together it'll be very lovely it'll be a
super fun relationship they'll love
spending time together close yeah after
all these years they'll finally hang out
come on man ah is not a word ah is
absolutely a word it's in the Scrabble
dictionary that's what I that's I think
whether the RNC likes it or not I think
VC is going to be the future of the GOP
they're going to they're going to push
back on him as hard as they can I mean
we saw it during the baates but there's
no stopping him at this point he's he's
got Trump energy and he's young I think
he is what what I what I said of aake
the other day is that he is the right
leaning leader of the millennial
generation that is to say I am not
saying he is a leader of all Millennials
I am saying of the
Millennials of the Millennials and
younger and and even some older people
but I mean he speaks really really well
for for Millennials of those who are
leaning moderate to right maybe post
liberal or conservative this guy is is
is on top of all of the issues I am not
saying for each individual person he is
the best candidate you that for you and
that you would like him I'm saying he's
he he h a wider base across Millennials
leaning to the right and so he is like
the front runner for our general and I
think with a slightly different
personality you know if he wasn't so
willing to be front of stage he actually
would have been an RNC top donor and
King maker in a lot of ways he has the
finances and he can spot where certain
certain issues are leaning I mean he is
good and he's well versed because he
recognized where there was an
opportunity for the Republican for the
conservative mement to grow and if he
again if he if he didn't want to be the
person in charge if he wanted a more
backstage presence he would have been
the guy that Ron McDaniels goes to and
is like please please please who do you
like please give us money to support
them and it would have been a a a
position of influence that I ultimately
hope there is a young Millennial with
good American first values but right now
V is sort of the leader in this category
I'm kind of I'm kind of leaning towards
uh
just Banning super packs and packs it's
it's tough because this conversation's
come up quite a bit in the past 10 plus
years where you have the citizens united
ruling a question of whether or not you
can give unlimited funds to Super packs
what are the rules and we all know that
these politicians are coordinating with
their with their packs and their super
packs they're just not formally
coordinating so someone goes out to
dinner you know a guy that I met my
neighbor meets a guy and they talk about
what the plan is and then I tell them my
plan and he tells them the plan and then
everyone enacts the same plan we get it
we get it
but my view is right now a lot of these
uh King makers as you mentioned you've
got people who work in big corporations
and they're effectively Shadow uh
candidates they fund someone else to
stand in front the argument for getting
rid of super Pacs and restricting
contributions to any any politician is
that only the rich would be able to run
and my is I'm like I'm like I don't care
about rich people well it's already like
that you look at all these people that
run they're all hyper rich like they're
all care if Rich congratulations my
issue is when some ultra wealthy dude
who works in a major pharmaceutical
company says I don't want to leave my
$13 million a year job so I'll just give
$5 million to this pack to get a guy
elected who will work for me make them
have to do it make them have to resign
from their positions or hand off the
position and then run for their $144,000
a year job they're not going to want to
do it was it 174,000 or what's what's
the salary I think it's 174 right yeah
something I don't know whatever that's
my point I don't know there's a lot
there's a lot of pitfalls there the
argument is you have a right to spend
money how you want if you want to buy
commercials you can and then people
argue all that'll happen is billionaires
will buy commercials for candidates and
so it's a it's an issue of yeah okay you
just don't allow that but it's almost
impossible to restrict because of free
speech you know if if I want to say you
know I like this policy should I be
banned from buying ad saying it that's
that's that's it's it's it's impossible
to actually figure out what the line is
going to be in legislating something
like this yeah it's really difficult I
think ultimately there's no way to
divorce American politics from the
influence of wealth um and maybe there
should be more safeguards in place I
think the the thing that I am most
interested in is uh the way that wealth
could influence smaller elections but we
actually see more political donors even
at at the you know the elite level
become active at the presidential I
would like to see people who have the
money like maybe they're shouldn't be
super packs but either way in the
current system that we have wealthy
donor hopefully would be more active on
a a local and state level and not just
only come out every four years the donor
class is always going to exist there's
really nothing you can do to stop the
donor class from giving people money M I
want to I want to jump to the story from
NBC News I love this how the GOP muzzled
the quiet Coalition that fought foreign
propaganda oh that sounds like the gop's
up to no good what's this all about the
FBI put a pause on briefings with tech
companies due to an ongoing lawsuit
adding to a broader breakdown in a
system meant to guard against influence
operations and to ensure election
Integrity I don't buy it for a second
these people are evil as evil can be but
let me read you the opening paragraph a
once robust Alliance of federal agencies
tech companies election officials and
researchers that work together to thwart
foreign propaganda and disinformation
has fragmented after years of sustained
Republican attacks man just reads their
propaganda
are so mean to the FBI they
just an illegal and
unconstitutional conspiracy between
intelligence agencies and tech companies
to silence the opinions of American
citizens has been thwarted and they're
crying about it you know what's really
funny when these things happen the one
thing you got to do is look to who gets
laid off what's this around the same
time that NBC is reporting the
fracturing of this government coalition
there's a bunch of layoffs being
reported at various digital media
Outlets I wonder why that is how much do
you want to bet the federal government
is illicitly supplying funding to
digital media companies to hire people
specifically for the purpose of lying to
manipulate the public well didn't Vice
just lay off some more people and then
completely shut down Jezebel's gone yeah
yeah Jezebel but that's just a public
service you know that's that's good for
no coincidence yeah no coincidence and
they're like you know what our business
isn't aligned and I'm not saying these
companies are funded by the CIA or
anything like that but there
are there if if you do the research and
there's a lot of stories that we've
we've talked about over the over the
years and stories that I've covered
several years ago you do often see this
there is government programs that
provide funding that typically get used
for propagandistic efforts we know that
the federal government provides
craploads of Monies to public radio
which gets they do this this game where
it's like NPR doesn't get government
funding and then it turns out that no
some other organization gets funding
which then provides funding to NPR so
it's circuitous but we see what you're
doing the CIA would never never fund
something to further push their interest
they've never done that right but I do
think it's interesting and that's all
I'm saying I am not saying I have any
evidence it's very interesting that
whenever you get these stories of like
government programs ending there's a
bunch of layoffs in the corporate press
huh how about that how about that so uh
what's the story about the tech
companies were colluding with the
government to suppress the free spee of
American citizens in violation of the
First Amendment they got caught the
Republicans are shutting them down and
now they're winging about it do you
think people read this for sentence uh a
once robust Alliance of federal agencies
tech companies election officials and
researchers and think these are the
people I want to have a
Rob this sounds like it really is
looking out for me the word integrity
that's true it it means the opposite
right uh but I I just wonder if the
average American looks at this and says
oh they are trying to pull went over me
because people don't trust the
government some do some portions of
Voters really trust it but a lot of
Voters are skeptical of it and so it
makes me think if you saw these words
strung together you'd be like this is a
good thing we don't want this once
robust but the way they write it they
act like it's such a big tragedy yeah
these these people are abject evil I'm
sorry the CCP is evil I think a l i
can't speak too much to Vladimir Putin
because I don't know enough about Russia
but he appears to do many things that I
would describe as self-interested and
evil but the CCP I think Takes the Cake
Russia may be a bit more vague and
emulous in terms of bad though CCP is is
just abject evil we can see the things
they do uh in terms of militaristic
expansion the way they seize property
the way they control the lives of the
people who live in China the videos of
people being tortured by police yeah
it's not a fun place to live I'm not
saying Russia is but you know they're
not as bad as a CCP still I'm not a big
fan of Putin but uh these intelligence
agencies and the things they're doing
this is evil I'm sorry they might sit
there and think I'm the good guy no
you're a crackpot evil desperate who
thinks that your life is better than
someone else's and you have a right to
dictate what they think and do you don't
you don't I'll tell you what my view is
my view is more like if the American
people believe stupid things they're
allowed to believe stupid things and
then the intelligence agencies are like
but but we have to go fight Putin and if
the American people are doing stupid
things will fail I'm like that's too bad
a decentralized system is better than a
centralized one and here's why if it is
that 60% of the Americans are so dumb
they vote for a dumb policy which causes
problems for this country and serious
ones it is better than if you have one
crackpot who believes tons of crackpot
things and then drives the country into
the toilet what appears to be happening
now is this country is no longer
operating in a decentralized way so we
are getting hyper centralized I
ideologically driven crackpot Decisions
by the Deep state which which is
destroying the country and then in the
meantime they're saying but it's
everyone else who's the problem dude let
Grandma post her stupid memes on
Facebook let people be wrong and let the
best ideas win you when you try to
control everything and regulate
everything we we look there's a great
meme Luke posted Luke rowski posted and
it's the private sector from 1950 to
today and the public sector from 195 to
today and guess what the private sector
it's like you know this this gigantic
box computer in a warehouse and then a
cell phone and the public sector it's
everything's the exact same nothing
improves what what these people do is
they're they are stuck in this stagnant
reality where they can't adjust to the
changing world and they think that the
pro the the solutions are going to be
50-year-old solutions they think that
they have to control the minds of the
American people but this stagnates our
ability to solve our own problems so how
about you let Grandma post her memes you
shut up and we'll vote for who we want
to vote for because we would be
infinitely better off if Donald Trump
won in 2020 than where we are today with
a crippled economy on the verge of World
War II hey y'all lost the Ukraine war I
don't even think Putin would have
invaded if Donald Trump was President
here we are next thing that's going to
happen is China's going to invade Taiwan
and Joe Biden's going to go bro come on
man and if Donald Trump was president at
the very least these things would be
happening slower but I also think they
probably wouldn't be happening at all
you see you see this the parallels
between how sensitive the CCP is about
control in information and about
criticism within their own country and
it's almost like America is I mean I'd
say slowly but more now now fastly
shifting to that same direction of you
have to censor online you have to
absolutely control Grandma's memes
online even if they're inaccurate or if
they're accurate and it's like America
is essentially becoming the exact same
thing that the CCP is trying to control
and centralize all this information and
they're just so sensitive you can't
critique the FBI you can't critique
these agencies and if you do you're
going to get censored yeah I it think
about the Twitter files right when when
Twitter files got released mainstream
media was sort of like we don't want to
acknowledge that we all knew this all
along and now we definitely have
evidence that there's collusion between
tech companies and federal agencies and
instead L later they're like how could
you guys ruin our awesome relationship
that we're actually very proud of it
seems like such a strange world and the
American voter is just expected to to go
along with it right I think that's the
most insulting part communism they
didn't expect Elon Musk to BU my Twitter
oh I know it's amazing it's a fun plot
twist and and and vah was crying and I
bet she cried a lot but but not because
it's like oh no an evil man is going to
make hate speech no cuz she's like he's
going to find what I said and that's
what happened and then you know here's
here's the crazy thing too I wish that
Elon just dumped all of it oh yeah he
didn't it was select it was searched and
there's reasons for it I mean there's
going to be stuff in there about
passwords there's going to be stuff in
there about
financials that's too bad I I I really
wish he was just like I I bought uh
Twitter and I'm going to publish
everything their entire servers are now
open to the public have fun well V on
Luke radowski's podcast after the uh the
uh debate debate yeah if I can speak
today um he laid out like almost a good
Five-Year Plan about basically releasing
Twitter files but for all social media
agencies and just really exposing how
deep all of this goes and how deep the
CIA and the FBI actually medal into it
mhm the v's basically going on stage and
being like anyone who's paying attention
to what's going on I have your answers
the problem is to win votes you probably
have to like there's a reason why these
politicians behave the way they do
because VI going up there and saying
listen this is a thing that's happening
a lot of people are going to be like
what's he talking about and then you're
going to get Ronda s or Nikki Haley
saying some you know blathering about
some mindless platitudes and it just
sounds good I think there is a very
serious division between uh those on
Twitter and those who are not on Twitter
and in America and it's it is weird I
mean news moves much faster on Twitter
and there's information that circulates
that becomes fact uh not saying it isn't
fact but you know becomes more publicly
known and then you'll get voters who
don't use Twitter or who are just only
really on Instagram maybe check Facebook
once a while and I I honestly applaud
those people right they're they're
probably just living their lives having
a good time on the other hand they are
not aware and maybe they would feel the
urgency uh but they aren't moving as
rapidly as everyone else it's like
painful to watch every day but you have
have to otherwise if you miss a week
then you miss so much but some people
can't they have other things to do you
know the meme of the two guys on the bus
and one guy's looking at the dreary
rocks other guy's looking at the the the
the you know the valley in the sun and
the guy looking at the sun is smiling
and the guy looking at the cliff is sad
someone posted that it might have been I
don't want to I don't want to drag the
wrong account but it was an account I
follow and the guy looking at the dreary
Cliffs side it said people who read the
news or people who watch the news and
then the people smiling said people who
don't watch the news and I was like the
problem with that is that it's
technically the other way around a lot
of people are like man the news is so
depressing though yeah but here's the
thing what it should be is if you want
to do that the guy who's watching the
news is sad but he's alive and the guy
who's not watching the news has a bunch
of needles in his back has a guy
stealing money out of his back pocket
his kids are being dragged Away by a
Creo and he's just like I have no idea
what's going on and I don't care and it
makes me happy it's like let the world
collapse all around you let your
children be indoctrinated and groomed
your money be taken to blow up kids to
get injected full of crazy whatever
drugs the doctor you know is claiming
you got to get and that's when you don't
know what's going on in the world you
don't pay attention you and your family
suffer and they suffer for future the
future Generations suffer those are the
same people that you know say oh as long
as it doesn't affect me doing X or this
you know if I as long as I can get a
beer at the end of the day then uh you
know it doesn't worry me but it worries
you very quickly when things start
hitting the fan as they are right now
yeah yeah I think I think sorry you
going to say oh well I was just going to
say Tim we had the I think um genocide
losing my mind reach it was our year
anniversary for that a couple days ago I
was reading a comment and someone was
like anyone back here A year later
thinking like wow they knew ahead of
time crazy cuz like it was before the
Ukraine thing oh I mean uh 80% of that
song was written 20 years ago true but
it was just kind of funny how we had put
that video out and like the bridge is
just like all the bombs and I'm like oh
sh mostly peaceful drums
the world is ending here's why it's a
good thing yeah we're making fun of the
media and then they're doing exactly
what we thank you for the plot ideas
this is nobody nobody beats the Babylon
be they had they wrote that article and
it said uh woke activist and and skin
head try arguing but end up agreeing on
everything and then someone was like
Babylon Beast strikes again and there's
an article saying like why are neo-nazis
joining Pro Palestinian protests yes
speaking of that Ryan long and Danny
polishuk video where it has like the
hardcore racist guy and then someone
who's like BLM every opinion is exactly
a line it's so great welcome to the
modern era man what a crazy time to be
alive it is a crazy time to be alive and
I think that's the thing that I love
about people who don't really engage
with the news is like they've got enough
on their plate they they can probably
tell you everything that's going on in
their Hometown in their office they know
everyone's birthday because their brain
is not occupied with trying to keep up
with everything I think it's important
to be engaged and be aware on the other
hand I'm sure people who are obsessively
following the news miss all kinds of
things and their personalize you have to
have a balance of these things let's
jump to this story from the American
Survey Center looks like it's a American
Enterprise Institute Generation Z and
the transformation of American
adolesence how gen Z's formative
experiences shape its politics
priorities in future and I need to only
throw it to Matthew eaus so we can give
you the breakdown of what they of the
one of the most important things they
found low and behold my friends gen Z
support for same-sex marriage drops from
from 2021 to
2023 in 2021 jenzi 80% supported
same-sex marriage today it is 69% lower
than Millennials higher than genx and
higher than Boomers but lower than
Millennials now that's really really
interesting Millennials approval for
samesex marriage went up Generation X
went up and Boomers went up and gen Z
went down so what Matthew agacia says is
that it's probably a fluke however he
goes on to say
I I do think we now have a good amount
of evidence that Zoomers are going to be
more conservative than Millennials but
this particular finding is just really
fishy sure that may be but the data
shows it and we have that uh right now
but we can see that there's there
interestingly I'll tell you exactly why
I think this is happening take a look at
this jz's unique teen experiences
percentage of Americans who report
participating in or experiencing the
following in their teen years gen Z
regularly attended religious services
52% Millennials 58 genx 64 Boomer 71
jenzi is down in religious experiences
had a part-time job 58% Millennials 70
genx 79 Boomers 82 had a boyfriend or
girlfriend
56% once again Millennial 69 76 78 drank
alcohol or smoked pot or cigarettes
occasionally gen Z absolutely not
smoking and drinking and then felt
lonely or isolated 61 % Millennials 57
generation x 44 Boomers 36 you want to
know why it is that gen Z probably had a
huge push back against same-sex marriage
in the past two years it's it's laid out
exactly right here they are lonely they
are isolated they don't have significant
others and they're feeling like this
weird Neo woke whatever you want to call
it world this cultural world is causing
them relationship problems they don't
see in the older Generations so
interestingly gen Z looks to Millennials
Gen X and Boomers and they're probably
thinking how come they were able to do
it what's going on today is bullish and
it sucks and then the old generation who
has it are like we should be more
accepting and Progressive causing
problems for the young people I also
think outside of all of this the biggest
and most important component here
is liberals don't have kids and 20 years
ago when jenzi was being created in
passionate love making
more conservatives had kids than
liberals and that means there are more
genz conservatives than liberals that's
well conservatives weren't killing their
kids at Mass like liberals do yeah the
LI liberals not only don't have kids
they abort their kids they're now
getting into uh practices which can
result in the sterilization of their
kids conservatives are still having less
kids for sure but I I tell people when
they say oh indoctrination and that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
two two reasons
one more conservative kids no matter
what means more conservative Future No
Matter What there's only so much
indoctrinating can do and it can
convince people it can change people but
it can't be as pronounced as literal
biological reality of human beings who
are created in conservative spaces so
like the indoctrination needs to take
place in areas where the left has
control or has taken control but
conservatives are pushing back in the
culture War which means they're losing
but more importantly the one of the most
important things outside biological
reality is the economic reality even the
child of a leftist family is now
wondering why it is they can't find a
boyfriend or girlfriend they can't find
a job and they feel so lonely and
they're looking around them and saying
everything we have is worse than what it
used to be and so you're going to get
people who are going to keep saying
return but with the V you know what I
mean I love this chart because it just
tells you the Baby Boomers were out
living life and then we restricted
locked down and plugged in gen Z I mean
every generation here got progressively
more online and gen Z was the first
generation to live through a lockdown
because probably more of them no but
these these experiences the culture the
community are really valuable things
they shape who people are and so the
idea that gen Z is worse off is because
they are actually isolated right they
are unhappy and so they're looking
around and saying we talked about this
once the fact that JZ especially you'll
see it on Tik Tok they're obsessively
trying on different fashion trends from
from decades before and they're saying
we wanted what you guys had were trying
to find what this is they want the baby
boomer life where they can go out
without their cell phone and go get you
know drunk in the woods with their
teenage friends or whatever kids did
because they can't do these things
because their life is perpetually online
and they have no social Community when
you see how cancerous the dating pools
are nowadays tooe this not had a
boyfriend or girlfriend I'm sorry but
the Baby Boomers didn't have the
situation ship you know what I mean like
they actually did something about it I I
have the answer for Jen Z listen if you
if you are wondering go to church
it's crazy I did not I went to church
when I was a kid stopped going around 12
never went again but I am telling you
it's not about just like some faith in
God or anything it is about being part
of a community that looks out for each
other and if you don't want to do that
that's fine you need to find a community
and build one up see the issue is for
the Boomers 71% were going to religious
services so of course they they were
able to have a boyfriend or girlfriend
of course they did not feel as lonely or
isolated surprisingly they drank and
smoke way more and this is pot or
alcohol or okay or cigarettes so they're
probably all smoking cigarettes to be
fair but the the reality is when you
look at this chart religious regularly
attending religious Services means they
are constantly in a social
environment and Jen Z less likely to do
so it was crazy I saw this video it went
viral like a year ago of this moderately
attractive like 20 4ye old woman talking
about how she was basically an incel she
stayed at home all day she had no
boyfriend and she posted things on the
internet and I'm like that's weird like
I can understand that for a 24-year-old
guy who does not know how to do these
things but I was like surprised to learn
man even for young women they're
experiencing many of these similar
things because it's not about whether
you're a man or a woman for the most
part it's whether or not you know how to
socialize or you are a terminally online
person mhm well it's almost like skewing
gender roles is a bad thing for dating
it's almost like women supposed to be
women and men are supposed to be men and
we have a mutually beneficial
relationship and when you start to skew
that it makes people more lonely I mean
no man is going to go hang out with
another man that was a woman and you're
not going to seek that exact same
relationship I mean some of you might
but it doesn't work out I think it
progresses into marriage too right I
mean as soon as we sent women to the
workforce we saw a complete collapse in
their more traditional roles like uh Vol
volunteering went down this is typically
something women manage in the home it's
typically women who organize the social
calendar and so so if you have two
working people who are obsessed all the
time plugged in their laptop job the
idea that there's community that they
Foster among themselves and among their
children just completely goes away
people don't take people don't realize
how important the gender rules were for
society they think it's just something
that happen to oppress women take a look
at this one jenz adults spent less time
with friends as teenagers this is crazy
to me Gen X 60% said during most or all
of my teen years they hung out with
friends 29% said during some of their te
years and 11% said not at all only 40%
of jenz says during most or all of their
teen years they regularly hang out with
hung out with friends that's that's czy
my mine is uh uh if someone asked me
during all of my teen years all I did
was regularly hang out with my friends
yo there there were points in my life
when I was like 14 I wouldn't go home I
would stay over at my friend's house all
night and we'd play N64 like the four of
us we were in I had friends we were in a
band together then I started
skateboarding my friend group got bigger
all we would do was go out and
skateboard all the time and then when I
stopped going to high school after a
couple months all we did was go out
every single day in skateboard it is
crazy to me to think that there are
there there were kids and gen Z that
literally were not hanging out with
friends but think about the effect of Co
right the internet and Co there was
literally years that high schoolers went
from being like like I know people who
were freshmen in high school the year
lockdown happened right then for the
next basically two years
yeah they gen Z and so they wouldn't be
in school I mean this is true of a lot
of people and if you're not I mean this
is true in a lot of situations you have
to start making friends to in order to
maintain friendship so if they never got
that introduction especially during this
age where socializing is actually
something the brain desperately needs to
practice then you are CH it's more
challenging to make friends it gets more
comfortable to stay online and talk on
Anonymous you know internet forums
whatever else the internet is good in a
lot of ways but ultimately I think a lot
of of people have been using it to avoid
practicing normal social skills that
baby boomers just did because that was
how we operated as a society this is
crazy take a look at this so uh
influence on Parental education kids who
had two parents were more likely
substantially more likely to take
private art or music lessons play a
competitive sport regularly attend
religious services and substantially
less likely to drink alcohol smoke pot
or cigarettes occasionally unsurprising
that two parent homes are better now
with no degree that's college degree
which is interesting two parents with no
degree was uh less likely than single
parents to play competitive sport I
think that one makes sense single parent
probably says I'm going to drop my kid
off at soccer practice so I can go take
care of business and then come back
later but still regularly attended
religious Services still uh less likely
to drink and and smoke pot still more
likely to take uh private art or music
lessons single parent across the board
seems to to have it the
worst and I think that's in increasing
there was a viral post that's probably
fake
but it was like a woman saying she was
seeking a sperm donor and I think I I
had a video about this earlier there's a
black market sperm donation thing
happening on Facebook where women are
like I'm trying to get pregnant so I
need a donor and it's just like it's the
weirdest thing this is what's what what
has evolved of procreation I seriously
think we're going towards pod babies
because women are going like I'm going
to keep my there's a movie about it I
forgot what it's called but it's like a
woman wants to have a kid but she's a
careerist so she ends up getting a pod
where the baby grows in a thing and they
put
closet which is a metaphor for mother
motherhood there right she's going to
have it happen somewhere where she's not
actually having to deal with it well you
bring it to work and then you put it in
the closet but it's like it's kind of a
bad ending anyway but I think that's
definitely where we're going one of the
uh big trends now is that women are
seeking unvaccinated sperm only but uh
in one of this posts the woman was like
I want to you know I I want a man to
come and don't and donate in person the
natural way and then leave and I'll take
care of the baby on my own this means
that baby has only a mom M mhm this is a
recipe for disaster for society Target
sells insemination kits now what what
what yes breaking news from me on they
sell it next to like all of the like
sexual care items you know tampons or
whatever else and condoms since when I
don't know since when I just notic don't
know about these things I guess next to
condoms it seems counterproductive CU
it's all like the Isles are near each
other I'm not going to talk about my
shopping habits but you know like the
thing is if you're trying to buy any
kind of care item for women they'll put
them next to like whatever it's saying
you don't need men for this this is not
something you need I mean theoretically
it's it could be U an Ode to the
same-sex Community right they're saying
young lesbian couple we have something
you are looking you don't need to get
itos that on the Target website at home
insemination set yeah and they've got a
they've oh man there's a picture of a
woman holding some uh you know with the
thing on Target on target I can't I
can't show this image on YouTube
oh guys don't worry Carter looks it up
he's like oh my God I got to see
this I would uh I would display it on
screen if I was allowed to on YouTube
look I think having children is great
but I think this is a
weird oh my God he was on way to much
Friday show are you serious I'm imp oh
no this oh oh my God there's a photo of
the woman you
like there's a like how to do it you
guys have looked at this way more than I
have it's on Target's website concerning
I just saw the box in the store oh
there's a how too good one of theot one
of the photos shows a woman's legs on
the bed with a hand coming down with it
and it's full and wow won't be full for
long we we that that video where the
scientist is walking through the room
has all the babies and the pods we're
almost there they grew that goat or
whatever that lamb in the bag right so
we are getting really close to being
able to grow life in bags no no I'm
sorry we can already do it the question
is will the government allow people to
grow humans in that movie where they
grow babies in in the pods they they
passively uh uh this you you know why
the movie was bad spoiler alerts
everybody I'm sorry the movie was bad
because they did not explore the
ramifications of pod babies it was just
about people who had a pod baby the
issue is at one point in the movie they
like um my child was born through your
services he doesn't dream and they never
answer what this is about and I'm just
like perhaps it has no soul or something
like that I don't know but is that sort
of what they're saying right people who
are trying to Outsource having to carry
children are also not actually that
interested in the children that they
create they don't care if they can't
dream they might braze it as a red flag
But ultimately it's about themselves
it's almost like a trophy that that
that's how I mean I feel like
childbearing in general is going
especially when you have like like the
same-sex couples just buying kids now it
almost just seems like a trophy at this
point and they're less caring about you
know having a mom and a dad and a
traditional family sorry we have to
ignore the the Middle School House it
looked like a CO test of some kind and
it was like all the sudden it's a it's
it's like a jelly you know those things
they used to put the jelly in the jelly
donuts yeah I hate it here this is gross
jelly donuts forever ruin
next hey hey hey we are we are talking
about the struggles of jenzi and how
they want to have families and why their
policies are changing and you mentioned
Target selling at home in semination but
isn't that weird that Target did not
bring this up it's weird to me that
Target would be like well let's just
embrace the fact that we actually don't
care if children have fathers present
we're just trying to see that there this
is this you can have a child and we
don't really care what happens like I
just I think you know your your family
planning business is your own but I
think ultimately we would like a culture
where it wasn't just widely accepted
that we expect the family unit to be
broken I'm calling it now at all like
these Pride rallies and stuff you're
going to start seeing Target
insemination kits being given out you're
going to see it in a few
years Next Step no but I mean this this
is the other thing like you know way I
think in like 2012 PE research released
a study saying that the children of
same-sex couples ultimately are not as
they don't Thrive the way children of
heterosexual couples do and this always
makes people mad right because they're
like how dare you question same seex
Community uh but ultimately you can't
live in a universe where you acknowledge
that samesex parents are not the same as
heterosexual parents especially when we
know father fatherlessness is one of the
main reasons that children struggle with
you know like women are more likely to
experience te pregnancy if their
father's not home men are more likely to
be incarcerated if they if their
father's not in the home well the
violent rates especially too children
tend to be significantly more violent if
they're raising a single person
household with just a mother yeah
there's no coincidence Ian I mean there
was that first grader who brought his
mom's gun to school and shot his teacher
oh yeah he's he's raised by a single
parent it's not to blame her for
anything well a single mother
specifically right yes so my my question
when we were talking about this on the
culture War podcast was are we not
tracking for the uh detrimental effects
on single father families so I'm I'm
wondering if single father children
raised by single fathers do better than
single mothers but but better and by
what metrics so what we find is in
education and less likely to commit
crime less likely to do drugs are we
checking Mental Health and Social
wellbeing along with that cuz I I I I
would wonder this based on just like a a
general biased view of women tend to be
more focused on social issues men tend
to be uh women are subjective men are
objective so when you have a mom and a
dad the dad is the disciplinarian or
he's the tough guy he's the leader but
the mom is the nurturing and the caring
and the social so my question would be
would we be able to track uh um over
large populations that if a child is
raised only by a father there less
likely to be emotive artistic creative
but more likely to be disciplined and
you know uh uh not doing drugs and stuff
like that I I don't know I don't know
for sure would check but but I'm saying
like we don't actually have studies that
track these things because we are
concerned as Society with are they
committing crimes and going to jail
because we got to pay for them if
someone's like I'm into math and not and
not literature it's like okay well we
don't really care you're allowed so
that's why we say you know single father
uh uh families do better than single
mother but then I think for the whole
human
experience without an either capacity is
going to be bad for us yeah I think you
need both and that's I think that's
ideal right traditional family W it it's
just you don't need two each I mean I
have heard that and I I don't want to
say this with so much confidence I had
read once that having like children
whose mom stay at home with they're
young uh read earlier like i' I've read
that there are benefits to that but
you're right ultimately are they you
know having children as children and do
are they going to jail is sort of
something we're measuring more more
intensely because it has an effect on
the taxpayer hey man this is really
interesting right here nearly half of
white genz women are liberal but that is
the headline I would not use percentage
of white Americans who are liberal the
majority of white gen Z are conservative
the majority of white Millennials are
conservative the majority of white J A
and Boomers the majority across the
board for white people in this country
they're conservative that's really
interesting
so gen Z only 28% of gen Z males
identify as liberal 46% of gen Z women
identify as liberal I wonder if they're
saying like liberal within like the
confines of the traditional Liber
liberal and conservative or if they're
saying like oh I don't want to call
myself liberal because I consider myself
leftist I wonder if that's part of it I
I don't know how much that would
actually sway the information maybe
you'd have to go into the cross abs look
at the questions and but that is a good
question oh I love this jenz and
Millennials were less trusting of
political leaders growing up and still
to this day good work good work
Millennials and genen Z equally based on
whether or not we should trust
politicians yeah I saw that it needs to
go lower it needs to go lower for sure
sweet sweet silent three look at yeah
look at them they're like I just believe
everybody they had no access to the
information that we have now this is the
problem with the silent generation
watching their MSNBC they're like but
Joe Biden said it's true so it is like
and he would not lie he is the president
of the United States mhm this is really
fascinating video games and and online
online gaming 7 and 10 gen Z Men played
video games in the past week I played
video games literally like 3 hours ago I
played video games right before we came
on this podcast that's right literally
10 seconds but you see that was work
because you were playing an an
entertaining
show what were you playing I was just
Mario Kart oh Mario Kart I was playing
balers Gate 3 nice yeah I I've beaten
the game like 47 times already but
there's just so many different stories
and Pathways you can take look at this
gen Z 71% played video games but even
more women play yeah but they're playing
Candy Crush yeah I mean even if they're
playing Sims 2 they are online thing
that's true they're they're doing
whatever they are they're avoiding all
social interaction at a higher rate it
looks like look at this graph compared
to the graph of loneliness in gen Z
amongst men too cuz men are now going to
video games for their social outlet
that's friends jenzie listen genz men if
71% of jenz men are playing video games
and 41% of women are playing video games
that means that right now outside there
is a disproportionate amount of females
to men that means it's it's almost two
to one two to one for every two genz
women there's one guy not playing a
video game well there's your opportunity
go get them
Tigers they may be at work though yeah
the parttime jobs I think I think the
challenge too is uh if you take a look
back at the other
metric uh these gen Z men they're like
look you got 72% of genz men are not
liberal and 46% of genz women are of
white Americans and so they're probably
meeting women and the women are like are
you into insert insane psychotic woke
thing and they're like no thanks have a
nice day I'm not interested this is
another reason why they're probably like
I am sick of wokeness I am sick of the
left y everybody's crazy dude that's why
you see the this like this new thing
about passport Bros you know leaving the
country is because of this it's because
they can't stand I know that from
personal experience it's like you
passport bro oh it's reality means so
you leave and go to like say Cambodia or
Thailand or Japan for instance to go and
find your wife because you can't find
anyone I mean yeah back in the day we
called them mail ordered Brides you got
them from Eastern Europe true they still
exist I will tell you this right now
though uh gen Z women are gay but
overwheling they think they are they say
that they definitely the majority claim
to be I meant that literally the study
says right here one and three gen Zan
identifies as LGBT they wonder why the
dating pool is absolutely it's so weird
but hold on gentlemen gentlemen if women
are playing video games and that means
outside it's nearly 2 to one for every
you know it's not necessarily that
they're it's they played a video game
the past week I get it I get it but my
point is if a third of jenzy women are
LGBT that means for these dudes there
should be tons of ladies out there and
you know a great a great opportunity for
you yeah you just have to go out and do
something about it I mean this is the
thing this is the issue right so the
thing about baby boomers that that they
lived in a more for culture right you
didn't have I'm going to text you on an
app and then maybe we'll hook up hook up
a couple times and then we'll leave and
we don't know what we're doing whatever
else there was more procedure in what
you're doing and I think that was an
open conversation in society it's not to
say that the Baby Boomers were perfect
it's just that this was uh this is a
social Norm that we have let go and I
think that makes it harder I think a lot
of young men don't know where to start
and
especially you know in the day and age
of me too a lot of men are afraid to say
like well I didn't know how to approach
her so I just didn't because I didn't
want to be a creep I didn't want to seem
weird and so we have to reinstate
Avenues of pursuing women that exists in
a way that everyone is like yes this is
this is a good way to do it because
otherwise you were stuck between men who
want to do something who feel like they
can't because you know whatever could
happen and then men who do something
about it in a really sketchy Shady way
that leavs women still a group of people
that do approach no matter what but
they're typically the the creepier kind
you I I got I got to say just back to
the original metric we pulled up that
gen Z supports same-sex marriage less
than Millennials and it's going
down people need to understand what
that's going to mean in 10 years in 10
years when jenz are in their 30s the the
a large portion of economic power is
going to be in the hands of people who
are increasingly uh rejecting same-sex
marriage this could mean within like a
generation or two you get the
overturning of overfill
like it it does not matter or I should
say it matters very little that you
convince someone of your ideas it
matters that young people are growing up
with the ideas and then eventually take
over the economy see a lot of people
seem to think that a lot of what's what
what goes on in politics is we're in a
constant Battle of trying to convince
someone to agree or disagree and there's
people in the middle being like well I
just don't know now the reality is how
many young people grew up in grew up in
an environment where they firly believe
based on the world view a thing is more
or less likely to be correct and so this
is what's happening for whatever reason
gen Z has rapidly rejected same-sex
marriage gen Z is going to have kids if
this trend is among them what's the
trend going to be amongst genen Alpha
and what comes after Alpha I don't know
it doesn't even matter you know all
conern this the beta but here here's
what's fascinating it was 2018 when we
saw that gen Z was slightly more
conservative in certain areas and now
it's being replicated years later in
different ways I'm telling you man it's
going to get I I I can't see the liberal
liberals in the left winning the culture
war in the long run I just and this it's
funny because I've been saying it and
now we've got more data lining to my my
uh uh my view of what's going to happen
if winning generational support is a
long-term game do you think that the
left got too confident that they pushed
the envelope too far initially they said
oh just don't go to church and maybe you
know let let you know people marry each
other and now they're like and also aace
gender and that was like one I think I
think the gender is really what's the
whole gender confusion and everything
that they've been pushing so hard down
everybody's throats I think that's
what's going to tip the scales in the
long run I think in general life sucks
for jenzy mhm yeah and it's not so much
that it's um you know I made a video
talking about how it's entirely possible
to succeed but it it doesn't life is not
always going to be easier for you A lot
of people look at Boomers and like they
had it so easy I should have it easy I
don't know you should go start from
scratch in the woods you ever watch that
ancient Technologies Channel learn to
build a mud hut and survive off nothing
there's a lot of great things that are
handed to you so it is what it is not
everybody's going to be rich but I do
think jenz is struggling with depression
they're struggling with uh uh like we
already saw
loneliness isolation and they're going
to blame the structures that were
created by the generations before them
but interestingly they're going to want
back what the Boomers had which is kind
of crazy yeah what was the percentage of
Boomer women who identified as LGBT oh
it's nonexistent 3% mhm hey things are
looking up guys things are looking up
how much how much of this three is jzy
women just saying that because they
think they need to fit in yeah even so
though that may be a reason why these
the like the the dudes are so pissed and
they're like yeah we don't want this
because that's lowering Our dating pool
by like 70% I think dudes want wives
they do it's almost like it's in our
inherent nature to seek the opposite sex
it's like literally how we're hardwired
and now that the dating pool is so
skewed and so messed up men don't have
anywhere to go and that is ultimately
going to build frustration until it hits
a breaking point and I think these
graphs pretty much take look at this one
most gen Z men say they are not
feminists nice good yeah interestingly
gen Z males and Gen X males are
comparable guess what ladies and
gentlemen which generation created gen Z
Gen X Gen X did yeah so I Can't Tell You
Why Gen X created a whole bunch of
feminists babies uh female ones but the
dudes are comparable to their dads isn't
that crazy sorry you go I was going to
say it's probably the shift in the
workforce of women becoming the the boss
girls that's probably the shift with the
feminism I think that's part of it also
every generation of women like the
majority identify as feminists and so
they think they're doing the right thing
they think they're doing what their moms
want them to do most of them what
feminism means here's the funniest thing
geny women are most likely to report
being treated disrespectfully by the
opposite sex I don't believe this has a
this is related to being disrespected I
think it's related to the hyper wok
ification and expectations so when you
have that video 5 hours of walking
through New York as a woman and quite
literally a man saying hi is considered
sexual harassment women are going to be
like I was harassed today when a guy
waved to me also they're they all said
they're lonely and they're not
interacting with anyone they don't hang
out with their friends so when are they
being spoken to inappropriately perhaps
on the video games
online Anonymous and there's no social
check to say you can't you can't talk to
women that way well and if you've ever
played Call of Duty and been in one of
those game chats that's kind of the
whole point yeah seriously so I I think
they should interact with real men in
real life and see if this is the same
thing it's also more socially uh uh
expected among genz and Millennials but
more so among gen Z walking up to a
stranger in public is taboo which is the
it's it's so crazy to me even for
Millennials a lot of people think it's
very difficult to walk up to a stranger
and talk to them I I would be surprised
if Boomers I I'd be willing to bet if we
did a survey and said would it be
strange uh or or or how would you find
it difficult to approach a stranger and
greet them and ask him how their day is
going Boomers would have it very be very
little low Gen X lower and then it would
be the highest among gen Z like
absolutely not there's there's all these
like videos where like I mentioned five
hours of walking in New York what what
was the one that just uh what's her face
um that one Twitter Woman made a video
of 5 hours of walking through New York
as a gay woman holding hands with
another woman and you the funny thing
about these videos is all of them they
only ever show black people and the
argument put forward by the woman who
made the woman who made that video five
hours of walking through New York said
it's because they edited the white
people out wow I'm sure yeah I'm sure
that's why but I mean like are they
lying or did they really do it I because
like you you can say I'm sure but I'm
kind of like either way it's bad I don't
know which one you think is bad it was
ENT say anything they're intentionally
trying to be racist or or they're saying
we edited the white people out because
they didn't do anything no she said that
she said something like white men did
harass her but they removed it from the
videos for some reason so either she's
racist or the white people didn't harass
her and so right so it's like hey look
look look look if her argument is that
she's a racist I'm willing to accept
that she's a racist and she made
propaganda whatever the point is look if
our if our view is this video is BS
you're not being harassed when a guy
says hi to you I'm going to go ahead and
say if this lady saying she's a racist
who was trying to smear a bunch of
minorities I'm going to take her word
for it and tell her her video's garbage
and it's it's not indicative of what's
actually going on in society because I
don't think it
is yeah I I the the five hours of
walking New York thing was so weird
because people showed it everywhere and
they're like it's so crazy to be a woman
and be like
really like this is it I feel like it's
not it was hard for me not to believe
that that video was edited some it was
creepy like a guy walking just walking
next to her for like five blocks and
then just disappearing I'm like that's
pretty weird well when you kind of
picked the worst city to film this in
like where I would say the large
majority of crepes are if something's
going to happen to you it's probably
going to be in New York or you can go 5
hours in La you're probably going to
have a very how about we do this how
about we make 5 hours of walking through
insert small rural Christian town as a a
Trad CAF woman you're just doing like
laps around the town cuz it takes you 10
minutes to get through the whole thing
no one says anything it's going to be
like there's going to be like a regular
guy mowing mowing as long as like good
day ma'am Hi and then she keeps walking
and that's it and then I know someone
who lives in a small town of woman and
she was saying she actually loves going
to the local grocery store because men
are always like you look so nice today
like hope you're having a good day and
then they leave her alone like I think
it's different when you're in a city and
you're already feeling like you're on on
guard right and I'm not saying that
people men can't be creepy on the
streets and that's important to like
recognize that women feel you know not
protected on the other hand like maybe
that's why she walk around with a man
who could protect you and they won't AD
should we should do a parody video where
it's like 5 hours of walking through a
small Christian town as a tra Catholic
woman and it's like she's got a basket
of apples and she's skipping and there's
a guy like howdy Miss and she's like
howdy sir and then she keeps walking cop
pulls up are you okay are you lost or
anything give a ride somewhere and then
it's like and then the inverse is 5
hours of walking through a small
Christian town as a libfem woke woman
and it's the exact same thing but every
time someone says
something a guy like how do she pepper
spray
aggression yeah okay y'all think I'm
joking but we're going for it I'm
playing this video I did a video on this
um uh earlier this is a clip from
catchup ketchup feed not ketchup as in
it's in catchup with the news and it
says uh quote I have anxiety I'm
indigenous I'm nonbinary it's a video of
a woman who was uh presumably driving
drunk the wrong way down the road and
she gets pulled over and this is what I
I'm sorry jenz but y'all are going to
have to uh have some explaining to do
here and so uh we're going to play we're
going to play this video for you right
now why are you driving in the wrong way
of traffic no I just got changed around
I just moved here like 2 months ago and
I just got changed around okay do you
understand what's going on though you're
going into oncoming traffic I know and I
just decided that it was better just to
turn around really quick okay but I'm
sorry I just have like really bad social
anxiety and stuff I I don't want to step
out whenever you're asking
for stuff okay well we're past that just
go ahead step out wow an indigenous oh
just wait it gets crazy yeah it's good I
saw clips of
this what sentence there as indous Perry
am well I'm non-binary so okay what do
you go byy
Kai how can I refer to you tonight Kai
okay hey I'm smelling alcohol this cop's
trying so
hard great job I need to run you through
some tests right now stand but I just
want you know that I also have very bad
social anxiety you and me both who
doesn't her face is I don't believe you
I'm the only one who got social anxiety
yeah I'm only I'm only I'm allowed to be
a victim yeah right focus on my finger
please I am you're just like trying to
intimidate me I don't know how I'm
trying to do that this is the test as
you know as an indigenous person and cor
with that one I'm sorry but it's just
for me to be on my toes I you can you
remember that I told you that a
nonbinary the hardest all right perfect
I need to know if you have any
for I'll
remember you physical injuries mental
mental
yeah
just ptsc compression anxiety your
medical history now with your right foot
place it in front of your left in a heel
to toe touching manner with your arms by
your side just like this
ma'am cop is being so nier he misgender
right I'm trying my hardest trying my
hardest okay means a lot to me I'm
trying my hardest I don't feel like a
man so okay it's kind of triggering
right Flo of your left nope go back
feels like it could be a par man thing
just like she saw I can't walk forward
now because call
me zero questions wait it gets crazy it
gets crazy here no but I just want to
tell you that I suffer from really bad
anxiety then don't drive right shouldn't
be driving with generational trauma and
oh my god dude stop how old is she she
acts like her ancestors were slaves
generation literally here we go it's
just just I'm going to speak with you
right over here okay no yes ma'am go
ahead and place your hands behind your
back just admit that you were drunk
don't make it hard please don't make it
hard listen no you're you're going to
get a resisting TR dude I you're going
to get a resist I don't don't resist
okay don't listen to me don't resist
don't you're being a white man
and I followed all of
your wo I did everything you said and
I'm getting in trouble you guys hold on
on so scaring me there's nothing to be
afraid what does it mean you're being a
white man I think we all know means
there's nothing I can do about it I've
been a white man my whole life it's a
slur she's using it like a slur y you're
being a white man kind to you no no like
this is this is an important point he's
arresting her yeah she's getting in
trouble she's claiming that you are
harming me you being a white man is an
insult to someone normally in her
circles I bet that works I bet when some
guy says something like no I'm I'm not
going to give you the last slice of
pizza she goes you're being a white man
he goes you're right I'm sorry here's
the pizza this cop is like lady you're
driving the wrong way down the road into
oncoming traffic I don't care you're
right sorry for yeah she admitted to
having three beers which is probably
less than she had too and she's like
reating what she just said like five
minutes ago too she's saying all these
things so she can be like well it's it's
actually that he was being mean to me
that I was
drunk she led with her excuses cuz she
know she's in the wrong you know the
advice that I was given was just don't
do the field sobriety test right and uh
don't talk and your worst case scenario
is they arrest you and give you the
breathalyzer back at the station and uh
I'm not a lawyer but I recommend
Consulting a lawyer more importantly
don't drink and drive and don't go the
wrong way down the road and uh well she
just moved here she doesn't know oh she
didn't she can't read Street sides they
were different it's the generational
trauma that makes it so that she got her
license in which you have to take a
written test to get your license but
then she forgot you can't drive the
wrong way down bring her ancestors and
stuff fast don't your sorry ancors the
Babylon bees got to got to make a parody
of this one they could go I don't think
you could
make this recent you know I got to be
honest you're you're you're actually
it's probably true I would like a
followup I want to know what happened
when she got to the police station I bet
this police officer went home to his
wife and was just he didn't even know
guess what happened
today that's amazing you're being I
might get brought up on hate crimes but
I I mean I would love it if she got
charged with uh like some kind of hate
crime charge you know I say that only
like half seriously no I think she
should because if the woke left wants
all these hate crime charges then if you
insult or attack or deride a person
based on their race then you should get
resisting and like invective or whatever
if she had looked at him and said you're
being a black man right now I know right
it would have been so different it would
have been so different like can you
imagine especially considering he wife
that's it would have it's complicated
then but like the fact that she can use
your your your being a white man as a
slur and we all kind of are like so
crazy except in another version of this
we would all be like that's a completely
inappropriate thing for her to say is
actually not okay because it's treating
one racial group in a way that we don't
treat others um so the the reason I
wanted to bring this up is we just did
that that we had that big survey showing
Jen's changes now I mean come on there
are a lot of sane and rational jenzy and
see it in the data they are pushing away
from this kind of insanity and they're
saying
enough I got to say like if I was a gen
Z guy and I was seeing this I'd be like
stop giving us a bad name man that's how
I feel I'm gen Z and I watch this video
and I'm like are you serious right now
I'm with the Boomers leave me alone and
this person only cares about they
themselves you know like they them I did
the best I could Kai only cares about
Kai right they Kai does not care that
Kai has been drinking and driving and
could hurt someone else Kai does not
care that Kai is going down treat Kai
has drinking and driving is a social
construct right Kai has excuses like
there's no tomorrow and ultimately
everyone should care about Kai even
though Kai has to care about no one else
that that's all I got this to drinking I
yeah that blows my mind you know I gotta
be K has generational trauma and
therefore Justified I'm willing to bet
single family a single parent household
single mother guaranteed I would say
guaranteed single mother household or
two mothers one of the two but most most
likely single mother what one thing that
always really offended me because this
happened a lot when I worked at Fusion
it Fusion was very leftist and woke and
that whole Trend started about the talk
and you had those commercials where it's
like you know uh black families have to
give their kids the talk and I was like
whoa what's that and then they showed
they played these videos where it was
like a black father talking to his son
and be like when you get pulled over
turn the dome light on engine off keys
on the dash wall on the dash hands on
the wheel and I was like oh yeah my dad
gave me that talk too and they went no
he didn't this is something that and I
was like wait wait wait hold on Legit
this is the yo I think you're talking
about rich people or something because
everyone I knew in my neighborhood no
matter what their race was got the talk
but there was this woke liberal lib left
talking point that only black families
get the talk and and for I'll clarify
the talk is when a father explains or
mother explains to their kids what to do
when you're pulled over by the police EV
every everyone I know of every different
race was told if you get pulled over
turn the engine off put the keys in the
dash turn the light on put your hands on
the wheel then when they ask for your
license insurance it's on the dash you
grab it and you can all your hands are
in plane view the whole time well I got
the talk and I come from a family of
police officers so that should show got
talk in driver's head they teach you
that in driver's head yeah don't hit the
gas pedal when you get pulled over don't
reach for something down because you
know they they're stopping you they
don't want to don't reach for the glove
box all these things that's why it's
like you get pulled over you put your
insurance on the dash you put your wall
on the dash you put the keys on the dash
they know you can't drive the car's not
going to move the lights on they can see
everything you grab your wallet right
there and you I just wait for them to
approach with my hands where they can
see them because like you put your hands
on Wheel so they can see your until they
ask you to do something then well and if
you're armed you let them know that
you're armed I mean at least in most
situations but it also can back that's
bad advice uh different states have
different laws on this and you got to
talk to your lawyer about that one some
states require it and some states don't
and some states create serious problems
if you needlessly start saying things
like that so that's I can see that yeah
don't don't listen to that talk to your
lawyer about
yeah cuz there's it's what I wondered
cuz if you're driving with like a gun in
your glove box and you have to get
that's usually like I'll have a gun in
the glove box and then you usually my
wallet's in the glove box or something
so and then you have to reach in and you
say hey officer I want you to know
there's a firearm in the glove box but
my wallet or my registration is also
there you can reach in if you'd like or
I can reach now you're can sending them
search your vehicle y depending on the
jurisdiction it can get crazy where if
you offer an officer to check the car
they can search the whole thing and take
you out yeah that's nuts to me yeah I
don't know if it's true though but uh
when I was a kid they said if if uh the
cop asks you to open the glove box so
they can see you've just given a full C
consent for the car correct yeah and
it's usually like some argument of when
he opened it I thought I saw something
so now I had to investigate and he said
it was okay that I searched it so you
know here's the important thing the
reason why you never talked to Cops
sorry cops the reason why you never talk
to Cops is because uh there's this great
uh Supreme Court Justice who went over
all the basics of it but there's really
one simple thing are you and the cop
going to remember things the exact same
way oh all that matters cop could be the
best nicest guy in the world and he
swears that you said that you were going
to shoot him up when you said I'm going
to root root him up for your baseball
team who knows he he could interpret
what you said incorrectly or mishear you
or something or you can say he says uh
what do you what you know what what are
you doing out here hey you're speeding
and you say just out having fun and he
hears just out with my gun and then he
goes I'm going to need to step out of
the vehicle sir then when you go to
court and you say he illegally searched
my vehicle the cop says the driver
informed me that he was armed I searched
his vehicle found Contraband or found uh
you know a possession of illegal
substances and you can say I never said
that I said I was just out having fun
and who's you're going to believe you if
however you say literally nothing then
he can't say anything he can lie and
then lie but but if it's a you know in
the instance you're dealing with a good
cop who's not going to lie he's going to
be like wouldn't talk to me you should
always keep it bare minimum I mean just
give them what they absolutely need in
that moment uh I would say give them
what you're legally required to give
them MH and then uh you know typically
just be respectful and say you know with
all due respect I'll wait let me know
when I'm when when you're finished it's
crazy how far respect goes too when
traffic stops people don't realize that
if you're just respectful bro in life in
life too especially in traffic stops
like in Texas I've been pulled over five
times in a matter of two years yeah I
don't want to talk about Texas are on
something El ginger
racism profiling straight up but four
out of those five times no ticket I've
had my well right so here's the
challenge I mean they'll you know I'm
I'm not a fan of lawyers I feel like
legal advice from lawyers is always I'm
just like look man situational I've been
pulled over I'm I'm driving the highway
and it's it's like it's super late at
night I'm in the middle of nowhere uh in
rural Illinois I'm speeding not speeding
too crazily and I get pulled over I'm
like and the cop walks up and like
how's it going there Budd you got
license and and insurance they don't say
license and registration and he's like
you were speeding and I was like bro I
got to go to the bathroom man I'm sorry
and he's like all right dude don't slow
down and he let me go no like if I gave
him the business I'm stuck there having
to go to I to take a dump and I'm like
bro I'm just trying to get off at neille
that that card works I will say liter
that card it works so it's it's like and
there have been instances where uh I've
it's not happened to me but my friends
have said that they they they were uh
snoody to the cop and the cop said I was
going to give you a warning but you're
being a dick so now you get a ticket
yeah so it's tough I mean you don't want
to admit to committing crimes or
anything like no lawyer lawyer would
tell you to do that but if you make it
easy for the for the officer and you're
respectful you might just you know right
tap on the top of the car and be like
come on man slow down cuz I got to pull
you over next time if you do it again
and you're like all right dude I got it
the other thing too is sometimes you get
bad cops right it's tough cuz you never
know if you're going to get a nice one
or not nice one
mhm never know how much you can say
without them using it against you my
advice would be don't claim to the
officer that you have anxiety
generational trauma are non-binary and
triggered or all of them or put it on
your ancestors come on what what are
they her ancestors are looking down just
shaking their heads likez I'm she says
she's indigenous right she did I have to
wonder just like Elizabeth Warren right
but but no no no let's let's operate on
the assumption that she is totally
indigenous I'm wondering if like her
commanche and ancestors are just like
she's not
ours used to Tomahawk people what are
you doing yeah right especially if she's
like you know she's Comanche or
something like that at least in her in
her Heritage they probably must be so
mad at her for this this whole situation
even like drinking the fire water come
on what are you doing drinking the fire
water come on what are you doing like
you're not eating peyote you're doing
this come on yeah seriously that's I
don't know if the kamanche did that cuz
they were they were would be like South
America fair enough but still Aztec
maybe you get point you're not rolling a
fat tobacco one there you go peyote
would be like New Mexico and stuff huh I
I imagine so I don't know too much I'm
not Joe Rogan so I have no idea not Joe
Rogan yeah and then IA would be South
America and then you have those uh you
have like the crazy cactuses what they
called like the that's peyote that's
peyot ohot is a cactus yeah yeah yeah
but I some like the there's another one
I forget what they're called um
different Cactus same thing doesn't
matter not
important still I I I fear for jenzi my
friends but um this data that we have
gives me pause and maybe I am uh more
hopeful for the future of this country
because of this data cuz we had a gen Z
person in the room say this is
embarrassing to us is highly highly
embarrassing I'm 23 oh okay yeah so I'm
like right on the I mean I was born in
2000 so I'm pretty close to the cut off
really what's the youngest
Millennial isn't it like 20 core is
supposed to be 92 which is my birth year
that's they say2 is a cut off for
Millennial center of it I heard the last
year of Millennial or like the last year
of millennial is 96 and ' 97 is the
first year of gen Z I think that sounds
right yeah as well yeah roughly the same
uh 81 to 96 according to britanica mhm
oh okay wow that's crazy but I kind of
feel like CU I told you the other night
like I am I feel like I'm right at the
end of the money that's crazy though if
you if you were born in 81 you were 15
when the other kid was born you're the
same generation it's weird that doesn't
make much sense CU that's why you get
the the zillennial Zen or
all I know is I grew up with good
cartoons I had the great cartoons I had
the Ed Ed and Eddie Courage the Coward
Dog oh come on those are great courage
was good Billy and Mandy Billy and Mand
Billy and Mandy was good but Ed and
Eddie was the worst I love they were
losers no they were losers for sure fun
they were they were out they were with
their friends constantly they lived on a
culac I mean this is what never Breer
but I just don't understand like they I
I just I never as a kid liked watching
shows where the where the main
characters lose and were losers
I you know why I like The Simpsons
because Homer was like he's forced
gumping about and it's funny and the
same thing with Peter Griffin I like and
Fry they're they're they're really dumb
but things turn out well for them cat
dog was a good one too I didn't watch
cat dog dog was crazy it was crazy that
was cat dog was kind of messed up though
yeah like all the best cartoons are a
little messed up though cat dog for
those who don't know it's like one end
is a cat and one end is a dog so you
have to wonder about how that works you
know what I mean it's kind of messed up
being that age though you don't you
don't think too much into it you yeah
but now it's uh with the weird what what
I guess the bigger concern is probably
for Jen Alpha because Elsa gate and the
things that that popped up on YouTube
with all this weird freaky sexualized
content is it's embedded in their brains
yeah right people need to understand I
love this um why does time fly as you
get older right it feels like when
you're younger like as you get older the
years are passing faster and faster and
fter
and it's mostly due to the fact that
your brain ignores uh uh routine it does
not need to store the same data as it
did when you were younger so from the
ages of like 5 to 10 years old it feels
like every year feels like an eternity
and you just can't wait when you're
older you're like wow I can't believe
it's been 3 years already man can you
believe the lockdowns were three years
ago seriously it's November of 2023 mhm
Joe Joe Biden's got his last year can
you believe it it's because we're not
tracking these things like when we were
young so for a gen Alpha baby or toddler
who's watching big breasted Hitler
Dancing With The Incredible Hulk it's a
real video I'm not that up yeah true
that's that's going to be like 7% of
their psyche because they've only been
here for a couple years and they watch
those videos for like eight months I
remember how impactful cartoons were on
me when I was a kid that's defin that
was my life oh dude yeah so it was uh it
was Richie's birthday the other day and
for his birthday we just did a of
Simpsons references and it was actually
fun and funny but offputting that we all
knew so much about The Simpsons and we
can't even tell you the articles of the
Constitution yeah like bits and pieces
article one section two says we just
listened to that right you know then and
then the Amendments but man you want to
tell me about how the Flaming Mo got
invented I can I can I can break down
exactly how it went down you want to
talk about the spruce moose just give me
season 1 through n of The Simpsons and
and I just we can sing the monal song
right now but now now you can't choke
Bart any longer more I never did either
and ab Simpson's gay I don't get any of
these ref I didn't watch scre up but it
makes me feel like I operated in a
different culture than you guys like I'm
over here you know I don't know what I
was doing I uh I watch the goats
SpongeBob SquarePants all the time oh
yeah of course spob Seasons only I was
to watch TV during the like during
school nights like Monday to Friday I
couldn't watch TV I could only watch it
on Saturdays and part of Sunday and so I
feel like it made me I could watch it
Friday nights actually but I feel like
it just made me miss all kinds of things
there's no you don't have enough time to
I'd fall asleep watching cartoons and I
wake up at 3:00 a.m. to Robot Chicken
that oh yeah that was so you had like a
TV in your room growing up no I mean I'd
sleep I mean I'd fall asleep in the
living room a lot of the times okay yeah
I mean you'd either wake up to Robot
Chicken or uh what is George what uh I
mean there's so many different
things Robot Chicken yeah but uh I'm
older than you so when I would fall
asleep watching Adult Swim I'd wake up
to like cab and space or the girls gone
wild commercial that's true yeah that
was always on and then it was it was
really great when adult swi got Family
Guy cuz then I was watching that oh yeah
that's true but yeah when I was man when
I was 16 you were you how old would that
make you two were you even here yet I
don't know I mean born in 2000 you're 37
yeah I'd be be right around there right
so I'm 16 watching Adult Swim and it was
like Space Ghost and cab and um oh the
Brack show is that what it was called
yeah bra yeah there's also like squid
billies was a good one I woke up I would
wake up to squid billies and that one
was messed up yeah that's like that's
like a later generation remember also
watching like tunami and watching like
Ron Kenshin and like uh who else like
Haw show Spirit detective was a big one
for me yeah inas Ino Yasha also a big
one for me and what else did they have
on that I don't know Dragon B Ronin
Warriors they had so many random shows
at that period of time yeah yeah Goku of
course Dragon Ball Z yeah I don't know
what they're doing now though no either
but I I also wonder too about like the
superheroes that the that gen Z and gen
Alpha have remember when Marvel did the
new the new Warriors that canceled it
but it was like snowflake in safe
space wow do you remember that remember
that yeah oh man let me pull that one up
snowflake see I grew up on like
Spider-Man and Iron Man those are the
go-to for me true I I grew up with Toby
Toby
McGuire to always will always be the
best Spider-Man and here's here's a
crazy thing like this was like a big
Scandal I guess when it came out I don't
know if it was a scandal but making fun
of it Snowflake and safe space and then
like quite literally at a morbid Le obes
Mexican woman who and her superpowers
she has a backpack that she can pull
anything out of she's from that arrest
video no she's Dora oh man no but for
real what what they were probably
thinking was the kids today the
teenagers who are going to read this
grew up watching Dora the Explorer let's
make a Dora superhero but here's the
crazy thing is Snowflake and safe space
are brother and sister and they're
really into each other oh I was going to
say there's Anar I thought they were a
couple this dude in the middle has
internet Powers whatever that means he
looks like a knockoff of Ben 10 did
anyone fluent watching D the explor
screen time look at this kid he's got a
meme obsessed super teen whose brain
became connected to the internet after
he got exposed to experimental internet
gas internet gas yes look at this one
snowflake and safe space Oh their names
match with what they look like for sure
I remember watching Batman mercilessly
beat a guy and then being like but we
don't kill and then in uh in in
Injustice too when uh Batman and Robin
and it's and it's Damen Wayne so he's
like League of Assassins when Batman
just crunches a guy's skull and like it
shows the X-ray in the brain cracks or
whatever the Mortal Kombat X-Ray and he
and he's like I don't kill and then
Damen goes yeah but TBI is okay I'm like
that's I love that degree of awareness
of agent with your audience right but my
concern with this is I grew up with
Heroes who are like you have to be a
good person you have to help others
self-sacrifice Etc they're growing up
with narcissistic arrogant whiny baby
Heroes this got canceled I guess good
probably for the best well now you see
this stuff gets canceled but then now
you got stuff like the boys the Titans
where the superheroes just Merc murder
and it's like the reality of the super
heroes he got like homelander mowing
down crowds gay vampire oh how
d telling you to V negative like at
least at least he's not HPV negative
there you go he was given a life-saving
medical procedure where he was exposed
to morbius blood as a child man I used
to look like full
Alchemist this Trailblazer look at this
I'm not kidding she's never walked a
trail in her life she's a it's a it's a
it's a fat South American one with a
backpack where she has a magic backpack
which is a pocket Dimension where she
can
pull useful random object she has to
sing back back back I mean that is
little monkey pops out she's
specifically against shoplift they just
got sued wow I I'm pretty sure they
canceled this and everyone was like yo
this is embarrassing that is a bad idea
I remember seeing Clips go around of
this on Twitter and everyone was just
making fun of it it seems again like the
Babylon be has struck you well it's like
drawn together but but not a joke right
it's not not even funny nothing's funny
about it it's so weird drawn together
this seems like something that like a
right- Winger would come up with just
just for fun and you're like it's a
little heavy know what I mean like it's
a little too on the nose save space Also
what are they protecting you from the
white men I don't understand yes yes
heteronormative
patriarchy I love that stuff though why
would they uh the marbles came out
officially today tanked completely tank
yeah the the reviews are are bombing
people don't want to watch it the
trailers show Robert Downey Jr and Chris
Evans from four years ago in endgame
because they know nobody wants to watch
it Disney has destroyed everything thing
South Park's roasting them for doing it
and Pander verse yeah the the first the
a really great example the um there's a
really great video I watched about uh
the fir Captain America versus Captain
Marvel and it breaks down why Captain
America was highly rated why it was
successful made a billion dollars and
why Captain Marvel was panned and and
didn't do as well and uh it's it's
really really simple Captain America
that's a movie that's like 2011 I think
what's the message being sent to people
in in in in 2011 so how how old you were
born in 2000 yeah so you're 11 years old
you saw Captain America y absolutely you
watch Steve Rogers throw himself on a
grenade to save the the other men who
are Captain America was great you
watched a movie about a dude so
desperate to fight for his country he
kept trying to lie his way into the
military now someone born in 2000
watched Captain Marvel where she Robs a
guy because he asked her to smile she
walks up to a guy she she's like lands
on Earth he's on a motorcycle with a
leather jacket and he sees her and he
goes you should smile more and then she
looks at him then the next scene is her
riding away with all of his stuff see
and I grew up on like Ghost Rider and
stuff like Ghost Rider that was it Ghost
Rider was awesome he was he was the peak
top tier he's a flaming head and rides a
motorcycle chains a flam a flaming chain
yeah a flaming chain and he's Eternal
and doesn't die ever so cool like and he
just does this for no is he fighting no
it's a devil's contract yeah oh what is
it he he uh he he signed a deal with the
devil nice immortality
was deal he he died in well he got in a
really bad motorcycle accident from what
I cuz he was like a stunt jumper
basically like evil coneval right the
devil said I'll bring you back but you
what was it like after you die you'll
work for me for eternity or something
pretty much yeah I don't know like a
Terri well then he ends up slaying like
demons and cool stuff and like kind of
turns on the devil a little bit a double
agent deal with God crazy yeah it's cool
I like I like the movie Nicholas Cage
yeah anything with Nicholas Cage is
always dude no question not the be are
you going to see that he's in one right
now uh about who he he's a professor who
like appears in everyone's dreams like
an4 film well he's in every
movie I was watching one where he's like
a buffalo Rancher just like before the
show started and I'm like I can't really
tell what's going on he can start in
anything and it will be entertaining it
could be the most Bland he may the the
best candidate to AI movie make did you
did you see the one where he plays
himself yes well I wanted to see what
was that one I think it was literally
called Nicholas cat the Fantastic life
it was the Fantastic life and then I
think it was literally his name it's
like he gets hired by this guy who's a
super fan and it's uh who's it Pablo
Pascal or whatever is playing the guy
and it's really Pascal Pedro Pascal and
then he's like there's this really great
scene where basically Nicholas Cage is
is is is informing to the government on
this guy who's apparently a drug dealer
and so Nicholas Cage is trying to go
into this room and the guy's like don't
go in there man please it's going to
change our relationship and he's like
this must be where the drugs are but he
opens it up and it's just the most
ridiculous Nicholas Cage fan room it's
got all his props and his pictures and
he's like what the dude was actually
just a Super Fan it was his brother or
cousin or something that was doing all
the bad that's so funny that movie
was good Nicholas Gage is the best the
the one I'm talking about is called
dream scenario it apparently just came
out or it's and he's he plays a college
professor who like starts appearing in
all of the kids in his lectures dreams
but then it gets like weirder and he's
starting like to do strange things and
it becomes an internet like it goes
viral and then he appears in other
people's streams oh really I want to
watch that have you guys seen
next it's a dating show Nicholas Cage
plays a guy who can see like a minute or
a minute and a half into the future oh I
feel like I've seen that and so he like
goes to casinos and he just wins
whenever he wants but he keeps it on the
deal and then he gets recruit or is that
your trick is that how you accomplish
that's how I yeah that's how I went
everything but it but it's actually a
really clever movie it's a really clever
concept you know I I recommend it co
yeah there's a great scene where he's at
a bar and then he sees a woman sitting
at sitting you know you know sitting or
whatever there's like a guy bothering
her so he gets up and he walks over to
her and then the guy's y it's it's her
ex yelling at her and so then he's like
listen buddy you know leave her alone
the guy takes a swing at Nicholas Cage
who can see the future so he dips
perfectly and then punches the guy when
the ex-boyfriend goes down the woman
goes you dick and then she runs to her
ex-boyfriend and cleans him up and she
says get out of here then time rewinds
back to Nicholas Cage sitting at the
counter that was him seeing the future
he gets up he walks over the guy starts
given the business and he says come on
leave her alone and then as soon as the
guy reaches to punch Nicholas Cage goes
here it comes gets hit in the face falls
down and then she goes to him and calls
the other guy a dick yeah Nicholas Cage
is the best man I love that I love that
he he's got great work uh kickass one
and two I was a f oh yeah well yeah I
forgot about those movies I love how we
went from talking about like the Imp
Friday to snowflakes it's Friday we're
chilling all right we're going to go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.net
Torres says howdy people howdy Clint you
are the first Super chatter I don't know
how he does it every single time he's
just hit and refresh non-stop he has to
be all right Leroy Hall says Trina Hall
started her transplant treatment today
please continue to pray for her during
this month long journey absolutely good
luck man wish you the best Shane H
Wilder says happy Veterans Day weekend
to all our vets also Tim I hope you
enjoyed the cast Brew meme with you as
Charles Atlas I dropped this morning
pieace I did not see it but uh also it's
it's the uh a birthday of the
Continental Marines MH so happy birthday
Continental Marines 248th yeah wow they
went and they stopped those pirates yeah
that's right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Tim stop I have ptst from generational
trauma and you're acting like a white
man but also happy birthday to my fellow
Marines and for the less lesser than
happy Veterans Day tomorrow not in my
tone
it sounds like a marine thing to say man
H says happy birthday to the Marine
Corps check out the commandant's
birthday message that is how to motivate
recruitment true yeah did you see the
new Army commercial all white men we're
going to war saw it right it went it
went in 2021 I saw the side-by-side
comparison of all the gender the we love
stuff and then now just all straight
white men it's like oh we are so bone
they went back yeah okay elf tree hug
says more D and D references please
I suppose uh I don't know I've been
playing a lot of balers gate which is
basically D and D good game good fun I'm
not your buddy guy says this is purely
political there is evidence problem is
would give the Dems an out for removing
Biden it's more likely Biden will lose
2024 exactly so I you know I've always
supported Biden it's those unequivocally
absolutely I don't like the Republicans
it's you know oh the Democrats wooo no
Biden's earned my
vote the
wink all right what do we got r j says
also Tom McDonald's Superman really
really hits it slaps huh it's a slap huh
it's a it's a it's a kids in your fun
lingo a banger a Bop a Bop they call Bop
for hip hop B for metal and stuff and
then slap you said Bop and now all I can
think is about is umop all right jonath
you're doing this to yourself Jonathan
Bernett says this Millennial is
officially a homeowner klouse and the WF
can choke on my Roberto chickens and a
garden coming in Spring congratulations
listen listen my friends we have too
many roosters okay we got too many
roosters uh we got a couple that are
hilarious they have mutton chops I don't
know why but apparently like one of the
breeds we had it's uh I can't remember
Kim knows all the stuff but it's got you
know mutton chops that come out and uh
they're they're just really dumb so
we've built the suburbs of chicken City
because the city is expanding due to
population growth and uh Kim built a
little shelter for them they don't use
so it's raining and they're all just
huddled standing there in the rain and
there's quite Lally a big shelter they
could go inside of but they're dumb but
we got to give them away they're male
they're going to they're going to build
their own shelter they don't need your
help yeah so I think we want we got to
give a bunch away and so I don't know
what are roosters is worth like 20 bucks
or something but but these are official
chicken City yeah genetic lineage you
know roosters so I guess 20 bucks is
that yeah 23 bucks 20 bucks we got to
get rid of them though we we were
planning on bringing them to auction and
just you know Finding good homes for
them but the only rule is you can't eat
them sorry yeah these are these are we
we are looking to sell to people who
need a rooster for their flock so they
can have more more chickens and more
roosters and not to just eat so there
you go true I don't know how we trying
to figure out how uh even oh yeah you
can tweet at Kim on on on X and just be
like I would like a rooster please
please a rooster Kim's going too fire me
she can tell she can tell if you if you
got bad intentions for these roosters
she she's like Santa she knows she has a
list she a list
all right all right Mike Z says thank
you Tim and crew for all you do since
it's Friday I thought I'd shout out my
good friend Kieran she makes amazing
artwork and is trying to influence
Culture by making her own video game
Ashes to Ashlin goes by agent Kieran on
Kofi what is Kofi never heard of that
before k k fi Kofi co-i for anyone
interested in
that all right rabert G sanbert JR says
happy birthday Marines drink responsibly
I wonder if uh we're going to see
anything going on
uh in the Char turn I think in the area
veterans you like a reenactment of some
kind or I bet all the VFW is are like
packed is is is Veterans Day a bank
holiday is like an official federal
holiday I think so I think so yeah I was
cuz I was kind of like oh I wish that
was on Friday or Monday right giv us an
excuse to be like we out some some
places do give you the Friday off if
it's on a Saturday but oh not here at
timcast where we work all the I'm just
kidding I like this job well they had
the parades last weekend so I didn't
realize that it was yeah I thought all
the celebrations were going to be like
that Monday or whatever but then you
know it's Saturday so true and there you
go I'll get you uh some crayons Raymond
and I'll make sure to get them to you
stat so crayons you can celebrate
properly yeah Marines eat crayons is the
the old adage Logan cver says I can only
imagine Phil and James Lindsay were
screaming at their screens watching
today's culture War episode kami's
always Li well so the the one thing I
can say is I really do appreciate ha
coming on and uh and Trevor uh Lowden of
course it was a great conversation but
things got heated when I made a comment
about bisi meaning the middle class it's
a it's a Mis it's a it's a misconception
that it means the ultra wealthy people
say bougie and things like that but the
bisi was quite literally the uh the
middle class people who had small
businesses and then when I brought that
up H told me no it doesn't mean that and
I was like wait what I'm like that's so
I looked it up and I'm like it literally
does and then he played the well
according to Marx what it means is and
I'm like here we go if it's going to if
it's going to negatively impact my
argument I will give you an alternate
definition which is comment typically
typically what we see of the left you
know see we we need Jackson and Phil on
one we need it on the same one we on the
exact same one it was supposed to be and
then Jackson didn't want to do it yeah
true I do it I'm going to reach out to
Jackson after this and say debate Phil
right now okay so Phil leonty wanted to
date uh uh Jackson Hinkle and then
Jackson wanted H to come and then Phil
said I agreed to debate you not HZ so
then Jackson didn't want to do it but H
still did so we got Trevor to come on
instead
we're going to make it happen we're
going to make it happen yeah I thought
it was good I I think it's good because
uh the problem is what like the
roadblock in the culture War episode
is Trevor is saying people aligned with
the communist movement and the Communist
Party are enacting these things and H's
argument was that's not communism and
I'm like isn't that always the argument
right I'm like hold on if you're sitting
here making this
passioned idealistic or real he says no
it's not ideal it's real I'm like okay
fine whatever if you're like they're not
real Communists cuz they're not doing
the things that communism is supposed to
be it's like how come every time people
who are communists try to implement it
it turns into this every time is it is
it is it that no communist exists
there's not a single communist anywhere
wasn't there a point where he was trying
to like remove marks from the equation
and say that it wasn't based on Marxism
when then he was arguing stuff from The
Communist Manifesto and and different
because I remember that part
specifically I clipped it the one where
he was like what is what do you mean by
work what do you mean by deeper yeah so
I I think the issue is I don't care for
this like rebranding of Communism it
makes literally no sense I do agree with
some of the idea of class
struggle arguments the problem is
cultural Marxism is absolutely insane
and disrupts from those who are actually
trying to create you know better systems
for the people who actually produce my I
I would love it if the workers of the
world owned the means of Productions
production and you know what I mean by
that it means that a factory is owned by
a regular working-class guy who built it
up and and earned that wealth and he has
private and free trade ownership and
Market of all all of it no government
intervention so for me when I hear the
workers own the means of production it
means the state doesn't own it and
massive multinational oligopoly so
basically how things were in America
before corporatism took over absolutely
so it's private trade private Enterprise
with a strong and robust middle class
that is what it means for the workers to
own the means of production because what
the Communists keep saying is the
workers shown the mean means of
production socialist say it and I'm like
yes with a regulatory state that has
final say you don't own it right so all
that all that I hear is the Communists
argue no no we'll let you use it but I'm
like okay then uh sign the deed over to
the guy and let him have absolute
control over his over his means of
production well no because then a single
person owns it no no no look if there
are a million factories and there are
you know you know uh uh a thousand guys
who own uh uh you know the or or a
million million people who own each
Factory and then and then a thousand
workers at each Factory that's the
workers owning the means of production
the problem for me is centralization of
power be it monopolies oligopolies
corporatism communism
Etc there we go all right Ohio man says
please for the love of God and all that
is Holy do not let Nikki Haley be
Trump's VP pick I can't vote for dick
cheny and heels can't do it Nick Cheney
that's going to stick that is going to
stick they have to know this though
Nikki Haley as VP is like no way Nikki
Haley anywhere near power is no way
scary I think they relationship's too
contentious I think their their fighting
has been too public but you know I just
hope Trump isn't feeling like is isn't
feeling like he's in a let's rebuild
some bridges kind of mood when he's
making a DP choice at this point he
should be a in a uh let's burn some
bridges mood with everything going on
Tucker Trump Carlson be so good and then
you can keep having Tucker do his show
on X too just do both I I I do think the
issue is they want a VP who's going to
capture a a different base that's
understandable and that's why Nikki
Haley seems I don't want that base
though keep that base away from the G
you want to win you want I know man
she's in I would love to see him pick
like I said the other night Chris kobak
like a really motivated AG who's doing
something interesting right there are
other options we are just looking at
sort of the headline people but
hopefully Trump has people around him
who are looking deeper than that seeing
what people are actually
accomplishing nonpartisan Kitty says
this is what's wrong with our country
it's always for the next election and
never about getting things done
now yeah it's always compromise it's
it's like the Republicans saying look
look I know you want to end omnius
spending bills but let's just do this
one right now and we'll work on this and
it never happens that's why Matt Gates
was like nope it's now or never baby
right and uh in the end I don't know if
he'll actually get all of it done but at
least he's pushing train that pressure
so I'll take
it all right Jeremy love says you guys
are terribly misunderstanding what he's
saying they are still Gathering evidence
and won't call it until they have
everything no no no no I totally
understand that is what he's saying and
the point is he had said previously we
have the evidence we have this right
here you can come and prove that you
it's not true come into our committee
testify but we have the checks we have
the documents we have the bank records
and now it's we don't have enough for an
actual impeachment so but I think it's
political strategy I am not saying that
he is saying this to betray the
Republicans I think he's like we don't
want to impeach just yet we want Biden
to roast we want the Democratic party
take as much collateral damage
politically over this as possible and
then maybe we'll we'll deal with it
later on and this is our path to slowing
down the impeachment process do you guys
want to take bets on when you think
they'll have enough evidence I'm
thinking take bets do you think I think
it's like November November 14th of 2024
you know after when they'll impeach of
when they'll say actually we have enough
evidence because that's after the
election right after the election yeah I
mean I I'm I I think that's about it if
I were Gonna Roll something out it would
be afterwards let him have 2024 October
uh October 17 interesting good old
October surprise okay so because
somebody write this down for me let me
actually check the uh calendar real
quick if you want a specific date in
mind I'm going to go with November 14th
that's a Thursday it'll make the weekend
more interesting I think they honestly
won't even end up doing anything I think
let it all F though October October 24th
because that would mean the impeachment
proceedings would begin and would not
conclude until after so actually
actually no I'm sorry I'm sorry if the
impeachment trial takes um how many days
was trumps it was like what like four
days or something wasn't that long
so they'd want it to
be they're when's the election it's the
5ifth right yeah it's November 5th so
it's gonna yeah so I think October 24th
is probably the right date because then
what happens is they're going to
announce on the 24th you'll get uh the
next week Monday Wednesday Friday and
then they'll say and then we'll come
back for the formal vote on the 4th
which is just before the actual election
that'll dominate the news cycle yeah Joe
Biden's under impeachment so what what
they want is with universal mail and
voting and early voting they want to
maximize the amount of time so
theoretically they could do something
like we're going to do two days of the
hearing of evidence starting on the 10th
they announce it and say this will begin
on the 15th our first uh preliminary
hearing the 17th will be our second
evidentiary hearing which will and then
we'll have the final evidentiary h on
the 24th and then it'll come to a vote
on the 31st so this way they they draw
out as long as possible that way the
month of early voting right right up
into the point of election Joe Biden is
is facing intense scrutiny the Press is
massively negative and then right before
the election they say he's impeached
yeah that' be interesting then the
Senate picks it up and they reject it
but election day is the fifth Carter
Serge you want to weigh in really quick
I mean that'll be a good strategy but no
you have to pick a date that's the game
oh the date um no I agree with Tim you
can't just copy Tim's idea sorry sir do
you want to go play October 25th okay I
think the go is so they V it all but
hold on understand are you saying they
will vote to impeach meaning the
evidentiary hearings already happened
I'm saying they'll announce they're
bringing impeachment charges so on
October 8th here's my I love this
getting more detailed I'm right roll one
of these 3% likelihood of happening
scenario very very low because there's
too many variables as of today I would
predict it's a Tuesday October 8th they
make the announcement they are going to
begin the formal impeachment process
which will begin with evidentiary
hearings in Congress so that members of
Congress can hear the evidence the
reason it'll be on the 8th is that
Tuesday is press release day they want
to maximize negative press it'll be on
the eth then there will be bickering and
back room nonsense for the rest of the
week they'll they they may have a they
may say we've had a few meetings
and then uh they might not do anything
for us of the week to be honest on the
14th they can say something like we are
now going to negotiate dates for the
evidentiary hearings in the impeachment
process before we decide to vote on
whether or not we will impeach so these
dates are going to be the 17th the 22nd
and the 24th after the 24th we will then
give members of Congress a few days to
go over the uh go over the findings and
back room deals and conversations which
means perhaps on the on the 30th a
Wednesday they could actually bring a
formal votee to the house floor now they
could theoretically move faster than
this but they have every reason to
maximize the duration of the impeachment
proceedings so that on the 30th the
formal vote happens which means that's
Wednesday nothing on Thursday or Friday
and then Monday it's it's it would have
to move to the Senate rapidly and they
could even hold it and say we have voted
to impeach Joe Biden the speaker of the
house will formally deliv deliver the
impeachment on the 4th the Monday giving
us time to have conversation discussions
about how this is going to be done
properly then it's one day before the
election and in the news the impeachment
is hand
delivered Or democrats remove Joe Biden
well before this happens what an October
that would be crazy great uh well look
look look if they're smart they do this
but they're not very smart are they to
be fair but Tim just spelled it out for
you no no no no no hold on I don't know
the deals that are going on in Congress
I'm just kidding the restrictions the
limitations for me it's very surface
level here's the here's a very
simplistic way you could draw this out
and smear Joe Biden in in in October
somebody somebody send this to Mike
Johnson there you go Mike Johnson is
like Tim stop telling everyone the plan
well the bigger problem is that
Republicans probably don't actually want
to do any of it and they're like oh boy
I hope we lose yep that's it and I I
honestly think that they will be torn on
whether they should move now they have
to get an alignment on on why this
timing is correct as opposed to
something else uh this game also reminds
me of when you guess like when your
friend's baby is going to be born you
know what I mean I feel like everyone
buy a
square yeah exactly we should do a giant
bingo game like that hilarious didn't we
used to do them for the debates you guys
did it a couple times oh yeah yeah yeah
it's hard to do though because you have
to make a whole bunch of unique State of
the Union that's when you guys did them
I think all right they bring up yeah B
tune says thanks for the yesterday's
shout out it was immensely helpful and
I'm deeply grateful well thanks for the
Super Chat sir yep hell yeah what do we
got Trent lalino says is anyone at
timcast looking into what's happening in
I know it's not front page stuff but
there's a potential for conflict as the
US Russia and CCP push forward here A
bunch of coups that were organic as well
yeah Sudan Sudan we talked a little bit
about Sudan Sudan Chad ni n Nigeria Etc
all those different people it's it's a
big story there's a lot a lot of
information there and yes CCP is pushing
a lot in into Africa and almost every
different nation of Africa and uh
everyone can feel it trust me we all
know about it sm69 says the Babylon be
just put out an article showing Nikki
Haley with a shocked face from the
debate with the headline Nikki Haley
stumped when asked which countries she
wouldn't
invade that was a good one wow yeah but
come on it's an easy answer you um is
the Maldives a country no the m is his
own country it is but it's going to be
gone soon it's the water's going to
cover it up so oh okay she I wouldn't in
North Sentinel Island that's technically
its own country right yeah good luck you
could say the Vatican that's a country
too yeah true is it okay there you go
own country
well there you go
I I might support that one though go and
D dig down in those archives let's see
what they got
right what do we
got uh Dallas Smith says doubt you'll
remember but we met at the rally in
Delta Park PDX after my boy Jay got
murdered I was tacked out militia style
keep killing it brv by the way I don't
need my red striped us Gator I loaned
you that day JK keep
it I ass that's to you oh he's talking
to me I was not in Portland yeah no wait
we do that cuz I know he's talking about
Jay Bishop Delta Park and pedx after Jay
got murdered he was tacked out milicia
style and he uh gave you a red Gator yes
I do remember you thank you for that red
Gator by the way no I I cuz that was uh
after night 100 in uh Portland that's
what got me to really start reporting on
riots was that video of Jay getting just
straight up executed outside that
parking garage and the ADL describes it
as an antifa AC activist who murdered a
right-wing extremist insane absolutely
insan crazy well if you look J's
background and stuff Jay was a good guy
I mean and then you look at the dude
that murdered him quite the opposite
Michael I mean had the shootout like
these these people they will go as far
as to murder people as we see but that's
really what starked my interest in
covering the riots was after that video
I remember I had I think it was like
$400 in my bank account booked a ticket
didn't even have a hotel at the time and
flew out to Portland night 100 I got the
feed on fire clip and then trump
retweeted it and that's really what
started my career but thank you for that
red Gator I appreciate you brother
chicken lady 198 says Tim please
consider inviting markk dice to be on
the culture War podcast he just released
a new book the war on conservatives
highlighting the culture War issues that
we have today I'm on page five good read
so far Mark Dice has a standing
invitation an open invitation and uh he
tweeted this he tweeted that he does and
it's just an issue of when he can fly
across the country but Mark we're all
big fans and we would uh love to fly you
out at anytime you wanted to come on the
culture War podcast and uh it'd probably
be good to have um mark on the culture
War podcast in the morning with someone
to debate and then Friday night IRL yeah
to hang out and you know shoot the
with the crew I already swore earlier so
I guess we're we're swearing
today wild Friday night Glen Grim says
shout out to Dakota he's seven years old
and is actively kicking Cancer's ass
join the fight give send go Dakota's
Army his family is asking for any
support in prayers God is good all the
time yeah hell yeah right on man good
luck good luck keep up
Dakota William U
uh uas or ubis UBS I think I don't know
UBS combat vet in need of major auto
repairs need motor rebuild or swap my
only vehicle and no resource is job and
Jeopardy can't go see my kid two hours
away give send go gbb 35 we are we here
at timcast are effectively a Craigslist
for you to post your uh willing to buy
and needs if you use give send go if you
use uh what's one called GoFundMe yeah
do that get out give some go I'm
independ like if someone doesn't go go
fund me I'll just say like hey you
shouldn't you on the risk of getting
banned and the problem is people are
like will you donate to my GoFundMe I
might but they might just just kick the
money back mhm yeah all right Kane able
says Hannah so which Target are you
shopping at to know that these kits
exist I'm kind of confused how you just
happened to stumble on that Stu busted I
I did walk through a Target recently I
did not buy anything um but yeah I it
was weird with the target boycott which
is that I live in a rural area and don't
go to Target that often anyways like I
had gone maybe twice in the last year um
so gets really easy to boycott things
when you don't go right if Walmart is
more convenient you go there anyways but
you know I have I have Progressive
friends I have normal Normy friends who
don't totally get it occasionally they
want to go through Target but no I have
to I have to shame my girlfriend every
once in a while cuz she loves Target
it's hard I hear her say Target no I'm
not driving you there I will say you
know it has been interesting watching
the Walmart near me really up its game
in terms of trying to be like we're cute
we're fun they're trying to comp so hard
I really respect it they're also paying
more influencers like just the normal
influencers that I would like follow who
I don't know if Target really did it
this much but I'm seeing a lot of like
Walmart partnership push hey Walmart
doesn't have insemination kits were they
really stepping up their game I don't
know or they that's the thing I'm going
to Google it right now jts says you're
right Tim I was raised by a single
father I definitely do better in
discipline area but have way less social
skills than my single mom friends
interesting but it's interesting because
if you have no discipline are you really
are your social social skills really
going to help you out you know what I
mean like you need both yeah you do you
need balance I think the issue is that
with discipline you can you can function
and survive but without discipline
you're you're going to struggle so even
with even if you have discipline but no
social skills you'll figure it out but
if you have social skills and no
discipline you're probably not going to
do so well true that's why we say single
fathers do better than single mothers I
think there's something still missing
from the picture but survival is
probably higher poly p say where is Ian
I don't know ask him uh he's gone yeah I
don't know he's G took vapor just just
gone L you guys don't like Carter that's
gonna hurt his feelings hey he's here
and he'll be back he will be back
neglectful sausage says we want young
kids to date more but we'll keep using
the term creep women are frightened of
average looking males creep shaming is
how we got here what I think the issue
is that men are scared of women like not
like it's not so much women it's the
fear of social pressure that they'll
post your picture on the internet call
you a creepo and all these things when
in reality you should just not care well
you've seen it with like the new gym
trend of you know men literally just
working out and then they get called
creeps or labeled certain things have
you seen the morbidly obese woman being
like incels they have like the neck
beard and like you know they like Cheeto
fingers and everyone on the podcast and
she's just drooping over her chair and
people are like Yo dude you know chill
my the thing about that video is most
incels are average looking dudes who
just don't understand what to do because
they were not they don't have the social
skills so I I do blame the parents quite
a bit but it's like yo look man there's
the old Trope of you know how do you how
come you see a short ugly guy with a
beautiful woman yeah is he like a is he
a movie producer it's it's all about
talking does he own does he own a
cracker Factory it it's not it's not
necessarily all talking it's
like a a beauty matters so to a guy
physical Beauty matters more than mental
capability but mental capability plays a
substantial role this is found in all
the dating the dating analysis the
reason why guys tend to want like women
in their mid 20s as opposed to like an
18-year-old or younger is due to the
fact they want someone who's more mature
I'd hope they wouldn't want somebody
younger no no you see this is the scary
thing the data found that when in blind
attraction tests men rated 14 yearolds
the the most attractive yeah
gross so when they show a picture so
when they show a picture to a guy and
say how would you rate this on a scale
of 1 to 10 the guys don't know the age
or anything about the woman they would
rate really really high for very young
women and why the models you see in
magazines and in malls and at and and
and like lingerie stores yeah they're
mostly like 15 16 years old it's messed
up right that's demented to me how old
is this study this study uh this might
have been 10 years ago so what they
found is actually guys are not attracted
to 14y olds they're attracted to 22 to
24 year olds and the reason is children
are not smart and hard to be around and
they will not provide for successful
families but that's the only reason well
I mean look that's that's horrible men
find young girls to be physically
attractive but not worthy of starting
families with not so it's like it's my
my point is ultimately that it is gross
like it's kind of weird that that's what
they found uh but ultimate attraction is
not absolute physical attraction for
guys it was are they mature and capable
of being a good Mom that's that's really
what physical Beauty opens the door but
if the woman is not showing the cap
ability to be a good mom then attraction
goes way down like obviously we are not
just like well you look good there are
guys who are like that for women it's
more
inverted being attractive opens the door
but for women it's more about status
capability confidence and so you know if
you're a dude you absolutely you you
don't have to be the tallest guy or the
smartest guy perseverance you know what
I mean yeah yeah that's what it's all
about so my friends what you can do
right now smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.net Watch the documentary
infringed and have your friends watch it
I am giving you permission right now if
you're a member of
timcast.net member and you have it in
your membership feel free to play it at
your local Club bar whatever and show
all your friends and uh encourage them
to pay attention you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Taylor do you want
to shout anything out yeah give me a
follow at Taylor USA t a y l r USA
spilled the properly way I mean the
proper way and uh go follow at watch
tenant now I'll be reporting a bunch of
breaking news and doing man on the
streets for them and uh tenet media on
YouTube and you can watch the culture
War episode from this morning clips from
the show will still be on youtube.com/
but the live shows will now be on the
tenant Channel that's awesome um I just
want to thank all of you white men for
being here and for being white men hold
on you're wel and the africanamerican
that's true except for most most of part
of Tim and mostly Serge uh it's just
been great uh let's go white men that's
gonna be a
terrible
dis here comes the Media Matters article
this out except for most of what I said
um I'm Han brimo I'm a writer for Tim
cast.com until Tim fires me at fire at
you should follow Tim fire you're
getting your own show now that's true we
just talk about let's go white men you
heard it here first it's a it's a new
show we're launching it's called why
white men are great yeah it's hosted by
me no I'm just kidding uh can't wait to
see it what was I talking about follow
timcast news on Instagram and X it's the
best you can see work for me and all the
other journalists they work so hard
they're excellent uh and if you want to
follow me personally I'm on Instagram at
hana. B and I'm on Twitter or X or
whatever it's called at HC bro uh over
to another white man white man Carter
Banks here make music here at timcast we
got a really busy week next week coming
up filming a music video for a secret
song also I think two music videos right
yeah two two to three maybe uh and then
we got our first live performance coming
up not going to say who that is but
working on that in December I'm I'm
gonna start Taylor Hanson with I'm gonna
start teasing it real quick uh I'm just
going to start teasing it a little bit
uh the one of the songs we're we're
we're putting out maybe the next one
maybe not no maybe not the next one
we'll see is a what what I would
describe as a um what do you call it
what do you call it when a guy keeps
hitting on a girl but she keeps telling
them go away it's that but for the daily
wire and us so like the daily so we're
it's I I don't want to say we're working
with the daily wire in a thing but
you'll understand when it comes out and
it's going to be hilarious you're not
the girl being hit on in this scario
you're relationship a little B what's up
and they're like like stop making it
sound so lame
no but I what I want to say is we're not
working with them but uh there is there
is a relation to the project and they're
excited for it and I don't want to say
too much because I I I don't know the
the degree to which we will we will pull
off a collaboration but I just want to
say like we have something that that is
basically done we got to do the video
for that involves the daily wire and
whether or not they're in on it as well
is going to be up to them but I know
like we've discussed thing so I don't
want to call it a collaboration just yet
because they may just you know Stand By
and clap for us but we'll see I'll be
happy with the claps and uh that's I
wouldn't say that happy the clap you
know what I mean this is going off the
rails anyway you can follow me at Carter
banks on Twitter you can follow uh
timcast music at timcast songs on
YouTube also shout out to my mom whose
birthday it was yesterday and uh what's
up Serge is trash house on sorry on the
social medias it is okay and it's at
trash house Rex most of the place shout
out to your mom oh thanks sir lovely
lady I've met her before uh why are you
smiling like that hey she's she's dope
she's lovely uh also shout out to Taylor
thank you very much for being here man
appreciate you uh what else um I don't
know just follow me on social guys.com
all right everybody we'll see you all on
Monday thanks for hanging
out